The joe rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
Lee Russell Peters.
I'm wearing my Cronk boxing shirt out of respect,
I wore my Cassius clay a sweatshirt.
Russell Peters has mad boxing knowledge dude.
He was a,
we were in the back main room of a,
first of all in the comedy store last night.
That was really good.
You know,
that's the first time we've ever hung out in a comedy club together.
That was really fun.
Yeah.
What was a,
it was me and you and who else?
Paul and Paul was back there.
Mike men was back there.
Mark Marin.
Mark.
No,
mark man was in the front.
We were all in the green roofs.
Trey Ho was with us.
[inaudible] just walked into the green room and he sat down.
Yeah,
so he was sitting there for a while.
Well,
he was,
it was real weird.
Like he,
he had a waitress take them back there.
The waitress took them back.
They're like looking for Josh Nasser apparently,
and she's like,
is Josh back here?
I'm like,
nope.
Josh isn't back here.
And the guy who was also,
it's okay.
Okay.
Like he tells her,
it's okay.
I was just hanging out with these guys.
So he came in and I'm like,
is this this guy?
Kind of like,
well what's going on?
So the guy sits down and a Rubin and Russell and I were having this like crazy
boxing conversation.
You know,
they're bringing up old fights from like the 90s and Shit and Roy Jones Jr bouts
and all of a sudden this guy goes,
hey,
you're still wearing the same hat.
That was his opening line is,
hey,
I have some,
some shock just still wearing the same hat.
It's not even an old,
I mean I got this hat last Chris look fucking brand new was when I looked at it,
what was the hat I was wearing last night?
Those paper boy hat,
but it had like a leather lip on the bottom.
It's very,
it was really cool.
I was like digging.
The hat's very nice,
Huh.
But it was just an opening line so that he could come over and talk to us and
he's like,
his eyes were glossed over and he's all fucked up.
And I'm realizing,
oh,
this is a crazy person,
just made his way into the green room and I'm looking around with those other
guys here.
They're looking at him like,
who is this fucking guy?
And I go,
hey man,
you know anybody here?
And he goes,
Oh,
I'm friends with alone.
Like he made up some named Jason.
Yeah,
fundraising model one 10 like it was some,
some person that didn't even exist.
So like,
hey,
you can't hang out here bro.
You gotta get Outta here.
That's what the,
that's the only problem about that place.
So you have those like leeches or this hangers where you're just like,
who are you?
Why are you in this?
Like,
no,
it was,
what was funny was because Ruben and I were standing there and the,
and,
and Joe's like,
Hey,
you gotta go buddy.
And he goes,
Oh and Nah,
it's cool.
It's cool.
But none of that now you,
you,
you're not a comic.
You got to,
you gotta get the fuck out.
Like I'm friends with this guy.
I'm like,
you can't see killing,
hang up,
hang up back here with us and interrupt conversations.
We don't even know you.
This is weird.
And then the guy goes to sit back down and Joe's like,
no,
no dude,
you got to leave it.
We're in deep into the comedy store.
Green Room behind the main room.
So you have to go backstage,
down the hallway,
down another hallway,
go through a where the piano is,
go behind the stage and then into the door.
Like this guy like made it through the catacombs to come back and hang with us.
What it was.
It would have been fine.
He would have gotten through it.
No,
if he was just not a crazy person.
If you just sat there and laid in the cut as they say.
Yeah.
But we were in the middle of this intense conversation and talking about Roberto
Duran and you know,
when boxing fans get together and start talking about old boxing fights and you
know,
you know about fights and I know about obscure show Mike Mccallum,
the body snatcher Ooh Shit.
And you start all the way champ.
Adas.
Yeah.
Milk,
McCrory,
Donald Curry,
all that shit.
You start talking about those.
And Mccallum was Jamaican.
Interesting.
He was a bad mother fucker.
Yeah.
I cried and I went for a run after he knocked out Donald Curry.
I remember that.
Knocked him out cold with a left hook.
The Motor,
the Motor City Cobra.
So sad.
It was so sad.
Donald Curry was supposed to be the next coming,
he was of lad motherfucker when he was at one 47 after he knocked out,
was it melt Macquarie that he knocked out and then he went up to a junior
middleweight or middleware and then he lost,
he started losing,
he got beat by um,
honey Lloyd Hannigan.
Lloyd Huntington.
That's right.
And that was an upset.
It was.
That was after he believed was English.
Yes,
he was a bad mother fucker too.
Very scrappy.
I met him when I was in England back in the day.
That was big worth Lik,
oh,
now he's,
he's shot.
Fuck.
That's hard to,
that's hard to deal with it.
So a lot of fighters that I bumped into her like that and I'm like,
Ooh,
it's terrible.
Yeah.
That's why I always tell them,
if you're thinking about getting out,
get out.
Oh yeah.
I didn't have a thought in your head.
Like,
you're not going to be a world champion.
This is going to be,
isn't going to be your
career.
You know,
buddy McGirt,
uh,
is a friend of mine.
He's crazy.
He's a,
he was a great fighter and he's a great trainer now.
Yeah,
he is.
He's fine.
He's fat,
he's happy.
He does look fat when he's training guys.
Oh he is.
But he's enjoying life and,
and I mean,
Nice.
And uh,
he told me,
I said,
what made you quit?
And he goes,
you know,
I had retired and then I thought somebody asked me if I wanted to fight for a
title and I was like,
yeah,
I do want to fight for a title.
So he said,
I,
I started my training camp and I was out there running at eight in the morning
one day and then halfway through the run I said,
what the fuck am I doing?
If I was training for a fight when I was wanted to be a fighter,
I'd be running at 5:00 AM I shouldn't be here at 8:00 AM.
I should have been here already.
I should have finished this already.
And he turned around and went home and canceled everything.
Whoa.
Said fuck this.
I realize that it wasn't the same person.
Yeah.
He was like,
if I was the guy who was really training for Fido,
it'd been out here at 5:00 AM,
what am I doing here at eight and eight in the morning?
Well
that's what's so exciting about this upcoming fight.
This one can between Jon Jones and Daniel Cormier Yang is it?
Both of these guys are training like wild bunch of it online.
They're talking shit to each other and,
and all the footage of them training like some serious intensity and the
training is really exciting stuff,
man.
It's a,
I tell you what,
I,
I haven't looked forward to a UFC fight in awhile.
Yeah.
I haven't looked forward to a fight as much as this one in a long time.
Well,
I look forward to all of them really.
I,
you know,
as a fan,
I look forward to
it.
But this is one that has Superfight status.
Yes.
It's like,
it's like the,
you know,
the Leonard Hagler type of situation.
Yeah,
totally.
Like I almost can't believe that they're going to do it this weekend.
It's almost like,
whoa.
It's all,
it's all,
it's almost too good.
Core me does look like a physically larger human being.
Well,
he's short.
You know,
Columbia is only a little taller than me.
I think he's five 10 but he's a fucking powerhouse.
I tell you what,
I'll say it now.
I think,
uh,
I smell upset,
buddy.
Really think so.
I think so.
Well,
it is possible.
I mean there's no doubt cornea is elite.
Columbia has never even been in trouble.
Not even for a moment.
Yeah.
Columbia,
he's beaten two former UFC heavyweight champions,
but then he trains with Kane on a daily basis.
Well,
not only that,
he brought in this bad ass Russian motherfucker.
I'm going to try to pronounce this name without goofing it up,
but uh,
I think it's gassed aloft brings in hold on.
Wrestler.
I'll Paul pull up the dude.
He's a wrestling base guy as well.
Cormy and correct.
Yes.
As is John Jones.
Yeah.
But I mean you,
you,
you know when you're dealing with somebody who's like a,
a stout little log like that and your long and Lanky,
it's really not that easy.
Well,
it's
way harder to deal with tall guys,
especially at tall guy like Jon Jones who knows how to work as height.
Yeah.
This is,
I'm going to try to say this guy's name,
I'm not going to try Jim Rod.
Yeah.
Maybe consumer Rod.
It's probably like a year.
No.
Right.
You're,
you're pretty good with different that our alums and stuff.
This gentleman in the front row,
uh,
let's see.
Oh yeah,
try that.
Cut.
Juma Rod Gasta love.
That's the love.
He's a obviously some total of Muslim Russian.
Okay.
He's a bad motherfuckers.
What he is.
God Damn,
that guy can wrestle.
I watched a bunch of his matches last night.
Where's he from?
Russia or former one of those break off countries.
One of the stands,
he was actually an Uzbek,
I think he's from Russia itself.
Um,
he was one of the first guys to a beat Daniel Cormier.
Any like,
he uh,
he beat down Daniel Cormier several times.
Like one of the best guys that that ever beat Daniel,
I should say.
Not One of the first guys,
but he,
um,
massive,
uh,
credentials behind him.
Five world championships for European Championships.
Anyone at Olympic gold Olympic gold metal.
Yeah.
This guy's,
it's is smart too and bringing him in.
Yeah.
Hey,
this guy beat me.
Maybe I should learn from him.
Yeah,
he beat,
he beat Daniel Cormier Yang.
Um,
submitted them in the 96 kilograms.
Athens finals.
What's 96 kilos?
It's two oh six or something like that.
It was around two 10 or something like that.
He's a beast up point.
Is that like,
I love the fact that this guy is this wicked fucking wrestler and he beat Corp
Mya and wrestling company.
He brings him in with them to train for Jon Jones.
The thing about Jon Jones Hall stylistically,
he's so
unusual.
He's so tall and he,
you,
he can hit you for like four or five inches before you can even touch him.
And he knows how to work his height.
He's the best at like Tommy Hearns Zeus to uh,
keep guys out with the jab.
Yeah,
very similar.
But you know,
Tommy Hearns,
I think,
uh,
Tommy Hearns,
well,
Tommy Hearns at that ridiculous one punch power that Jones doesn't,
it doesn't totally have yet.
You know,
if he ever is going to have it.
I mean,
he's 27,
he's more of an accumulative striker Jones,
you know,
he could grow into his power to maybe,
but Tommy would put motherfuckers to sleep.
Emily put Roberto Duran the second round.
I'll cold.
Good Lord.
I thought he was dead.
That was that.
That was the package out knock out of the 80s it was face down.
It was hard to see Roberto Duran go out like that too.
It's almost like I didn't believe it was possible.
Like that was how like opponent's got knocked out.
You know what I mean?
That's how guys who you never thought were going to beat Terry Norris got
knocked out.
But when you see a guy like Roberto Duran,
a living legend get CalEd like that,
it's really hard to believe.
And then Duran had the bout with Hagler after I went the distance,
ironically.
You know what I mean?
And actually just tends to be the beast of a puncher.
Back then I had more respect for Duran,
I think.
I think hang on,
had a lot of respect for Duran as a boxer and didn't want to do anything stupid.
That's after Duran and beaten Davey Moore,
right?
Yep.
They resurrected his career with Davey Moore.
Yup.
And then he did it again with a ran Barkley in 1989 that's right.
You know,
Davey Moore died,
right?
His car fell on him.
And he was fixing his car in his driveway.
It fell off the bricks and fucking crushed them.
Oh,
that sucks.
Fuck man.
What do you even do if your friend's trapped under a car like that?
I mean,
you gotta get a Jack under it.
I'll start asking around.
Who's got AAA?
What a scary way to die smushed under a car.
I think it was,
it was a good car,
not a Camry.
Right?
Camry is a bull ring.
Everyone.
And
um,
there was a thing on Iran,
Barkley the other day that he's like homeless.
I've,
oh,
you know what,
a friend of mine and my cousin lives in Brooklyn and uh,
he trains at Gleason's every now and then,
uh,
and uh,
Barclay Trans fighters there for five bucks or 20 bucks or something like that.
Wow.
He'll train you for like an hour for five or 20 bucks,
something really ridiculously cheap.
I ran whatever you have.
Really.
You got five bucks,
he'll take it and you have 20,
it'll take it a world champion.
You know,
I'm a world champ.
Tommy Hearns remember that?
Yeah.
You know,
I still actually,
I remember that vividly because I remember watching it live when he fought
Duran.
And I still think Duran Kinda got the,
I don't really think,
I think Barkley should have won that fight.
You think so?
Yeah.
Because Duran Duran got an a out of a,
you know,
a legendary status and a nostalgia and he knocked the Barkley down in the 11th
round.
Right.
And uh,
you know,
that was a good knock down,
but Barclay was winning the whole fight of them,
then I would have to go over it.
But,
uh,
there's a lot of bad decisions in boxing.
Did you see the,
uh,
the Tim Bradley Diego Chavez fight?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
He beat Diego Chavez like eight out of 12 rounds clearly.
And they gave a,
they give it a draw.
Yep.
Well,
no.
You know what it was,
I think Chavez came on strong enough to make a disputable.
Do you think so you think it was a very reasonable decision?
I think just a draw is better than a loss.
It's definitely better than a lens.
And when it's,
you know,
it could go either way with boxing,
a lot of times what I think is,
I look at it and I go,
I,
I think they're probably like if,
if you had a look at something like that,
they're probably happy that something like that happens.
Like that kind of controversy.
Cause then people talk about it and then they have a rematch.
Yeah.
Who would be excited about it?
Tim Bradley.
Diego shopping other than t Diego side Chevez and timber atlas.
No,
nobody would give a shit except for the fact that this decision was disputed.
Like when a decision is disputed then people get excited about the rematch or if
someone gets fucked over like Pacquiao.
Bradley.
Yeah.
Nobody really wanted to see that again except for the fact that pack y'all got
robbed in the first fight.
Yeah.
And when people ask me about that fight and when,
when a patio eventually did win the title back,
they said,
did you see the fight?
Where do you think?
I said I think Pacquiao out one more convincingly when he lost.
That's true.
That's funny.
Yeah.
Pack you watching.
Pack y'all get knocked out by Marcus is another one of those Roberto Duran
moments where you're like,
that was a,
that was a scary one.
Crazy.
Like you never saw that.
I mean,
you've seen him get tagged,
he seen him get dropped,
but did you just get piously sleep punched?
Just starched.
Oof.
Yeah.
That was,
um,
that's how,
that's how Kevin Rooney got knocked out by a Alexis Arguayo.
Same way guys.
Right.
A third way.
It was good.
And I,
Kevin,
I remember on Alexis Arguayo made his comeback on,
it was like ABC wide world of sports.
You on Saturday afternoons five Billy Costello a Odom and everybody's like,
Oh shit.
Alexis Aguayo was back.
I remember even when Aaron Pryor came back and he was still blind in one eye and
they still gave them a license.
I'm like,
are you fucking crazy?
And prior was blind in one eye,
legally blind in one eye.
And they still get my license.
That's like the great all time box controversy,
right?
Him and Alexis Shark whale.
When Panama Louis says gimme the other bottle of that I mixed.
Yay.
He gives it to Aaron Pryor and he comes out like a demon.
No,
no,
not that one.
The other one?
Yeah.
What could you drink coke?
He was into,
into cocaine.
That was liquid coke.
Did they have he drink it?
I don't know if they had it back then that,
but I know they have it now.
They have like these little advising type things.
You just go and you could also just drink it I guess.
Oh,
so you thought that was just a shot in a bar?
Liquid cocaine.
Now I was at the name of a shot.
That's the name of a shot.
Liquid cocaine.
What's in it?
Uh,
I think like fucking red bull and horse shit.
When you shoot a,
this liquid coke up your nose,
it works just like regular coke.
Uh,
I've only done it like three times,
but,
but it,
it,
it didn't seem like it was effective at all.
It just seemed kind of like a,
I don't know why.
Why?
Why did it take you three times to be like,
all right,
I ain't enough.
I mean it at the same time.
It was the same day.
Meaning like this girl had it and I was like,
what?
They make liquid cocaines yeah.
And I tried to warn it,
it's,
it's just like,
it's just like a Flonase or whatever,
like in your nose and get it in.
There isn't one of those like advising bottles or something like that?
Yeah,
yeah.
Yes.
It's they,
that's how they make it now that they sell it that way because girls can just
put it in their purse and it doesn't look like you're going to the bathroom
during the line.
They just pull it down,
go back to what it just looks like you got advising.
Yeah.
And then there,
wow.
Nosing,
no scene.
They didn't really work cocaine culture.
You know,
we were talking about that last night too.
Billy Corbin,
the guy who directed cocaine cowboys one and two.
I was thinking though,
smashing pumpkin.
It's different guy.
Totally different guy.
But uh,
he um,
you know those documentaries we were talking about them.
Corbin,
How do you spell those?
Smashing pumpkins.
Capital B.
Org Corgan.
It's core again versus Corbin.
Corbin Benson to others,
but we were talking about like Florida,
that cocaine culture,
like the cocaine culture,
the 1980s from like whenever you get cocaine in the mix,
like,
like when we're talking to them about that restaurant or the bar that we were
all at once in Scottsdale,
like we're in the middle of this bar,
you know,
we were working on the Tempe Improv and we went out that night to Scottsdale and
we're hanging out and uh,
Brian goes,
everyone's on cocaine.
And I go,
how do you know?
He goes,
look at them all,
they're all talking and they're all playing with her nose.
And I'm looking around and everywhere I look,
people are going like this and everyone's doing that.
I know he's got some sort of knows issue,
but I've never done cocaine.
I'm almost sure when I'm on stage,
sometimes it,
my nose is itchy,
be like,
go,
he's on coke.
I'm like,
not what this fucking knows Jesus Christ.
I can't afford to do coke with this knows I wouldn't be,
I'd do lane's not lines.
You're welcome guys.
And this joke brought to you by Joe Rogan experience and the Toyota Camry.
The upgrade,
you drink a little,
but you don't fuck with pot,
you know,
and fuck with it.
No,
I'm not a,
uh,
I've never had,
it's not that I haven't had good,
I never had,
I never had a bad experience,
but I never had a good experience.
I just had no experience.
And I was,
you know,
when every time I tried weed I was like,
yeah,
this is kind of like a nothingness.
Said I don't need in my life a nothingness.
I felt nothing.
Like I just felt zoned out and I didn't like it.
Uh,
you might've gotten a hold of some of that fucking snoop Dogg,
we'd,
you know that those guys smoke.
There's a lot of guys smoke that,
oh Gee Kush,
that's,
it's almost like a narcotic.
You know,
I didn't like the feeling of sluggishness cause I'm already a lazy fuck to begin
with.
You know what I mean?
Blessing Anita is a,
is a,
is an enabler.
I'm 100% convinced that everything affects different people in different ways.
I know people can't drink coffee.
They drink a cup of coffee and they fucking,
oh yeah.
If the walls,
they just can't do it.
I Shit my pants,
I usually ship right away after I drink coffee and then I'm good.
It's amazing how that works.
What's going on with coffee that makes you shit?
It's the caffeine.
Is that what to be done?
Well,
when I get up in the morning,
I drink a big bottle of water and then I go down and drink
my coffee and I'm drinking this organic coffee.
I get in Malibu there.
Um,
it's made to like coconut cream and fucking coconut,
raw sugar and blah blah,
blah.
She get it from a local vendor or something like,
yeah,
there's like,
there's juicery.
Ah,
so you go down there and you get a coffee and it's as cold coffee.
It's fucking great.
But it gets you wired.
Oh,
like cold brewed.
Yeah.
We've got some in the back,
so I'm cold brewed.
Caveman is crazy cold brew coffees.
Interesting.
It takes a long time to make apparently,
cause yeah,
when they run out they don't make anymore.
I'm like,
what do you mean you're not making any more?
I thought he just took regular coffee and made it to call.
No,
it's not ice coffee.
Yeah,
no brew tastes totally different.
What's the difference?
You just have to talk to Tate about the process but it takes hours.
It does.
It's not something that takes like,
like you pour the hot water and you mix it in.
Like if you use like a French press is what?
Which we use.
Yeah.
You use a French press,
you pour the water and you wait less than two minutes and then you press it and
pour it and then the coffee's ready.
But with that shit,
that cold brew stuff,
you have to,
it takes a long time.
Yeah.
Cause once they're out for the day they're out.
Do you want some?
We have some.
We have any back there.
I'll take some home with me.
I won't take anybody.
So I'm good with this one.
Okay.
I've already had the one fucking coffee.
I'm going to be wired.
I'm going to give us some cups.
Jamie.
Let me try that shit.
Let me figure out what the fuck the differences and I switched to American
instead of a ice coffee and that's a huge difference at Americana is a espresso
just mixed with water.
We're an ice coffee.
It's just brewed like regular coffee but stronger.
What's the difference between an American and a Kimora?
Come on guys.
It's a paintbrush.
Um,
the uh,
the Americanos,
his tastes watery me,
I would just ask for half the water.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I like Espressos and I like coffee,
but I don't like Americanos.
I always like the Chai.
Chai is an Indian guy.
Tried to,
let's see.
Chai means tea in Indian,
so we won't be saying Chai Tea.
It's like saying really know,
trying to just meet tea.
We're so dumb.
We don't even give a fuck.
We already explained that to Starbucks and like what the fuck ever.
Why you still talking to us?
We're making money here.
I almost have to ask for an extra pump.
An extra pump of Chai.
Yeah.
And My Chai Tea,
coffee bean makes it better.
They actually use the spices and they make it the right way.
Oh.
So Starbucks is using some sort of liquid?
Yeah,
some sort of liquid shit.
See,
caveman sells it in these containers and they ship it to you cold.
So like,
look at that.
It looks like this.
It looks like a fucking spray can like you look like a propane container.
Yeah.
Like a spray paint.
I'm like,
yeah,
this is a cause if you drink too much of that,
you're going to tag the bathroom,
which is like a cold brew concentrate.
Oh,
this is concentrated.
So we need to add water to this.
Three waters to warm your coffee.
There you go.
Okay.
Tell him to do it.
Just do it straight and see what it tastes like.
Yeah,
that's a good idea.
Can we get a red bull?
It's probably like lethal.
Yeah.
So Russell peed is,
what's the latest?
I see you got a special coming out with my friends.
No,
I don't.
Or You just did a special,
no,
I'm on tour.
What was this?
Uh,
I saw something.
Um,
oh no,
it wasn't special.
It was a,
there's like some interview with you that I was watching where people were,
they were saying,
how come you're,
how come people don't know you but you're so famous.
They were trying to figure out something.
I'm like,
what are you talking like maybe the people you're not hanging around with.
Russell Peters sells out the fucking o two arena in London two nights in a row.
You sell out these giant ass places.
And I was watching this person interview you and they were saying like,
well how come you're not more known?
And you're like,
what are you
the fuck he wants?
And it's funny,
I I,
that's why the tour is called almost famous.
Oh,
that's what you call it.
Yeah.
That was probably why she was bringing this up.
I remember when I was doing,
I was doing good day New York a couple of weeks ago when I was there promoting,
cause I was doing Madison Square Garden.
It's a whole bunch of fucking,
it's a whole process to get that coffee open just as weird dude.
It's like a pull tab.
I'm sorry.
Got It now.
So I was doing good day New York and there were like end of the morning show be
but like so almost famous.
I mean come on,
you're already famous.
I go,
if I was famous I'd be on Good Morning America right now.
I'm fucking good day.
New York
is that famous?
Like it's like there's certain levels of fame like you have to be famous to get
on.
Good Day New York,
but you've got to be really fucking famous.
You can be mediocrely famous on good.
And I say I submit to you that you really want to be on good day,
New York and not on Good Morning America.
Cause if you're famous enough to be on good morning America,
you're probably getting annoyed.
More like people were probably like,
like Tom Cruise would be on good morning.
America doesn't fucking dude can't go to the store.
Do you think Tom Cruise can go to the grocery store?
Probably.
Cause I think he's deceptively short and people aren't expecting that.
Um,
Danny devito short,
do you think?
See I heard he's pretty short a top gun too.
I think people say that shit probably because they're jealous.
I heard these five seven that's not what Jay Moore says.
Well,
you're more studies five nine Oh really?
But Jay mom never known what that dude,
how tall is Tom Cruise?
Siri doesn't know shit.
Tom Cruise is five feet seven inches tall.
It's a pretty sweet.
He's my eye.
How weird is Siri?
What does sharing all of that?
Why did I know?
First of all,
why the fuck did I know?
Nevermind Siri.
But Siri,
Siri
can actually answer that now.
Before Siri would like send you to Google now,
like an answer.
Like she answers with their voice crazy how fast you did.
It's much more improved.
Right series actually useful.
Now
they keep on doing updates to we're also where they don't.
How tall is Brian Red Band?
Here's what I found on the web for how tall is Brian Rennebohm?
What's the first thing that says Brian read been?
First of all,
talk about you ask how tall is Russell Peters?
Oh,
that's a good one.
See if she knows.
We're trying to figure out if you're famous.
That's right.
This is disgusting.
So
after all that process again,
it's like liquid or it's like cold espresso.
How Tall Russell Peters
let's me have a look.
Okay.
I found this on the web for how tall is Russell Peters?
Try.
How tall is Joe Rogan?
Yeah.
It says I'm five 10 I'm actually says that.
How tall are you?
Okay.
I found this on the web for how tall is Joe Rossi?
We just figured it out.
Tom Cruise.
It's famous.
Wait,
they're not famous.
How tall is Kanye West?
Checking my sources.
Oh,
okay.
That doesn't make sense.
You know what it is.
Everyone knows Tom Cruise does five feet,
10 inches tall.
Perfect.
Kanye West is famous.
That's the difference.
That's insane.
One you call Siri and you say,
how tall is Brian?
Red Bat and Siri says,
Brian Redman is five feet,
eight inches tall.
Then it's time to quit.
Yeah,
cause then you got two famous.
You fucked up.
Yeah,
we're all,
I think we're all at the right amount of family.
We're under the wire.
That's where you want to be.
You want to be under the wire.
You want to,
you don't want to be that fucking dude that's no out there.
John Travolta in it at Nice Hodgepodge.
Worse at nighttime after his wife goes to sleep.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Maybe they have an arrangement.
I think they do.
You think?
Yeah,
probably one of the down there in Florida.
Yeah.
Rocking it.
Rocking at Florida.
Things are happening over there for them.
I've only heard Florida is a different different world and were talking about
that last night too,
aren't we?
It's a different world.
It's a totally different world.
There were wild people,
man.
There's a lot of stupid shit like you'd see in the news like you were following
the Florida man Twitter feed.
No.
What is this?
Oh,
it's awesome.
Florida.
I'm finding some of the fucking hilarious.
It's all things that a man in Florida,
it's gotten arrested for recently.
They keep a track of all the rest,
man.
Twitter.
Yeah.
Here it is.
This Florida woman as well.
By the way,
the,
the tweet,
the guy on the front has tattoos all over his face.
Cops pull up to find Florida.
Man pointed a gun at naked neighbor over loud music.
It's like they always say Florida man vandalizes psychic girlfriend's car after
she tells him dead grandmother will return to rape him in his sleep.
I mean if you're dead grandmother was going to come back.
I mean she's going to come back to do that.
Yeah,
it's just a,
it's a super entertaining Twitter feed.
Another one is a stripper genius.
Have you,
have you ever read stripper genius?
No,
I'm missing out a lot in my,
on my social media now and just very limited stripper gene.
This is also true.
It's like people who work in strip clubs,
they like here things that are hilarious and then put them on store per do they
send them to strip a genius.
We started,
we started a couple of them,
my friends and I and then we just abandoned them.
A band.
You get started some fake ones?
Yeah.
What,
what?
What'd you have?
One is a,
one was a fuck,
what was it called?
It like wrong tweets or something and just like we were just,
anytime a disaster would happen,
we would send out like some sort of a,
it was called off color tweets.
We started,
have you ever read?
Yes.
You're racist.
No,
no.
Yes,
you're racist is really good.
They find like Super Racist Shit that people tweet like I'm not racist,
but,
and then they'll say something to fucking racist and so yes,
they're a shitty disclaimer.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yes.
You're racist was going off during the Ferguson riots.
That's a,
that's like I'm not gay,
but you know.
Yeah.
See,
these are really fun,
man.
Oh listen to this.
I'm not trying to be racist,
but come the fuck on.
Why did we end segregation if this would be the outcome
that kid last night on the,
uh,
the chocolate milk kid.
This is hilarious.
He are treated with what the actual fuck.
Wta F not trying to sound racist,
but why is a black girl with black hair playing Annie?
Wow.
They can't even let fictional characters change.
Well,
it was,
what,
who was it?
Who's mad at,
uh,
the Black James Bond coming out?
A lot of people,
all the man,
Idris Elba is going to be the new black.
I mean,
he's British.
It's all about,
isn't that all the criteria should be,
you should just be British.
Well,
it sucks because that Daniel Craig was the best one ever seen.
Great.
He was great.
He was a killer.
I believe that he was like,
he was the first guy believed at all.
I never believe Roger Moore.
Roger Moe was a little lightness.
Loafers.
Sean Connery was back in the day.
Was it different sort of character,
but like the kind of guy that Daniel Craig played,
like I really believed it was actually him.
Yeah.
Rush Limbaugh rush.
Oh,
he went crazy about black bond.
What does he give a shit?
He's not even fuck you rush.
What he,
what?
He can't.
Why can't they make two at the same time?
One with a black guy,
one with a white guy.
What are you good?
He who gives a fuck want to be a chick to be James Bond.
One could be James bail bond.
Margaret Cho.
Margaret Cho as James Bond.
It's just,
that's her name.
Her name's James Bond or fucking parents are crazy.
The name of James Bond.
She's angry.
She's had to kick some ass.
She works for the European secret service.
Just happened to be Korean.
Yeah.
They don't like,
they don't like change.
People don't like change.
What did Russell say or what did,
um,
he says that James Bond is a white and Scottish.
That's who James Bond is.
I know it's racist to probably even point this out.
And then he said Daniel Craig wasn't Scottish excellence in broadcasting,
but the franchise needs to get with it.
Right.
He continued the franchise.
It needs to be hip.
The franchise needs to get with the 21st century.
That's right.
We had 50 years of white bonds because bonds is white.
Barn is was never black.
That just seems very stupid thinking.
Not to sound racist,
but I hate when black bitches.
Thank you.
Supposed to be scared of them.
Like,
bitch,
I will pop you.
I mean,
I think black bitches is already a bad start to that sentence.
If cops are out to kill black people,
why are so many murderers alive in prison?
Oh my God.
Yeah,
there's,
there's a lot of the man,
I like twisted logic.
These,
this is actually the real problem with reading these things.
As you go down a rabbit hole,
when you go to like,
yes,
you're racist or something like that,
and you go down a rabbit hole because you'll find someone that writes something
really racist.
Then you go what?
And then you click on their page and you go to their page like,
Oh,
fucking Christ.
And it's all just racist shit.
It's just like all this fucking dumb racist shit.
And then you see the people that they're retweet and go,
let me see this.
Oh Great.
Yeah,
they,
they don't have a,
uh,
a deep swimming pool of intelligence happening there.
Yeah.
This is a bad one.
Woo.
I just went down a bad one.
See,
I just did it.
And if you,
if you go down these things,
he'd go and read these PE.
It's like,
how do you fix that fucking guy?
You know?
How do you fix the guy who's that fucking racist?
Is that racist?
And the problem is now they have outlets.
Exactly two minute,
too many fucking mental cases have outlets nowadays.
And that there's a weird free expression thing.
Like,
I mean,
you could kind of do whatever you want as long as you're not saying hate speech,
hate speech.
If you're,
if you're saying derogatory,
negative things.
Or is it only hate speech if you're,
uh,
if you're saying that there should be violence against them.
I Dunno,
it's,
it's a tough call and depends on who you ask in that one.
Yeah.
I mean it's obviously racist,
right?
But at what point would they remove it from a website for being dangerous or
inflammatory or,
or all of it.
It comes inflammatory.
Railey flammatory yeah,
for sure.
But it like what point?
Like,
you know,
like you can't threaten someone.
You can't say,
you know,
I will come to your house and I will fucking kill you.
You can't say that.
But you can see,
I can say somebody should.
Yeah.
You can say,
Oh,
Mike is a fucking moron.
I'm so tired of his stupid shit he sold.
No one could stop that,
but can you say all white people like Mike are fucking morons and I'm tired of
this shit.
You right.
You can't.
Right.
Okay.
Most people will let that slide.
But if you start saying like,
all black people are fucking morons and you put that on a website like,
whoa,
okay,
what's going on?
Like what?
Where do we allow like,
and then you start using slurs,
all niggers,
all those specs,
all,
you know,
you start going down that road.
All kikes I seen a lot of antisemitic shit online when the Israel thing was
going down.
When the Israel Palestine thing was going down,
a lot of people were angry for sure.
I mean there's obviously,
it was a horrible,
tragic situation to have these country's at war and all these people,
innocent people dying.
But God damn that I read a lot of fucking antisemitic shit.
No,
it's fine.
You know what the ironic part about that that is,
is that a,
they're both Semites that is true,
right?
They are both semiautomatic religion.
Yeah.
So when you're being antisemetic now you got to decipher the white ones are the
brown ones,
you know.
Well now he did.
He had a bit about that in 2006 in my shiny happy jihad that if you watch,
if you watch like Israel and Palestine and TV,
it's hard to figure out who the fuck is who.
Yeah,
I go,
you got a brown skin dude with darker hair,
throwing rocks at a brown skinned dude with dark curly hair holding a machine
gun.
Like how the fuck the higher powered ones are?
Our U s backed,
he compared it to the uh,
sisters.
Oh Yeah,
the William Sisters,
the Williams sisters play.
I can't tell who's who.
One of them is bigger.
Yeah.
One of them is more clydesdale,
bigger media ass.
Good Lord.
One comes from great horse stock from fantastic athletics stock.
Do you,
would you ever be into dating?
Like a really powerful chick like that?
I could check that.
Like you,
if the,
if there was someone chasing you,
she would outrun you.
Could you rule out run Serena Williams?
No.
No,
not with those funds.
I couldn't imagine it.
I bet she could outrun most men.
Right?
I mean,
if you had to.
Oh yeah.
That's a factor in
she's an athlete and,
and if you're not an athlete,
yeah,
well you might as well let her win that race.
It's worst.
I think if you're dating an athlete and she's,
and you're a comic and she's funnier than you,
then that's bad.
That's really where you're going to draw the line.
Yeah.
I know dudes who's girlfriends are just as funny as they are,
would they don't do comedy and you're like,
damn,
dude,
maybe no,
maybe they can't just figure it out.
And that's what the guy keeps arounds.
You think it's way harder for a check.
Yeah.
Wait,
harder for chicken.
Do comedy.
Right.
It's not harder for them to do it.
It's harder for the audience to accept it,
but I think,
I think that that time is passing now too,
because there's been enough funny women out there consistently enough that that
that you don't do the,
Oh,
fuck a chick.
Yeah.
I remember,
I remember when I started 25 years ago when a girl would walk on stage and we're
like,
oh,
let's go to the bathroom.
But now you know the women have stepped it up and they've gotten out of the out
of their comfort zone.
Damn.
They just,
they're just doing funny shit.
Yeah.
There's a lot of that for sure.
This is definitely the best time for women's comedy.
Yeah.
Best time for comedy.
I think I ever,
I don't people who've really see you,
you're your new shit that I saw you working on last night and I was like,
God damn it Joe.
I fucking hate you for being that brilliant.
Oh,
thank [inaudible] sweet.
Really good.
You guys don't know.
Thankfully you see it.
Well that crunch of putting out a CD or putting on a special and then the crunch
of coming up with a whole new hour.
That's the fun part.
It makes you be creative.
I mean,
you got to work.
You know,
I've been doing two sets of nine,
three sets a night out there hustling.
Yeah.
I did a Monday night.
I'm doing tonight.
I'm doing tomorrow night.
And it was just like,
if you,
uh,
if you just keep hammering at it like that,
good things happen.
It's just we have got to pound it out.
You know?
He can't sound it out in your head.
No.
You Go,
well,
you can
definitely get some bits that are almost ready,
like right away from your head.
You just come up with them,
you write them down,
you're like,
oh,
this,
this will work,
you know?
Yeah.
You know,
this will work.
So I'm gonna use that to wedge between these two things.
I'm trying to work.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I always do that.
I always,
I like,
some guys will go up with a completely like empty,
like sat,
like none of this stuff they've tried before,
but I almost always try new things out in between stuff that I know already
works.
You have to,
yeah.
I mean,
you're not up there to bomb.
That's,
that's,
you know,
that's not our,
that's not our fucking job.
It's a tricky,
tricky little tight little dancey do though.
Right.
It's like you definitely don't want to bomb,
but you don't want to continue to do the old stuff that you know works well.
I'm in the middle of a tour so I'm,
you know,
I'm at this point where I want to go onstage,
but I don't want to cheat the audience in front of me and do the stuff that's
already in my act right now.
But at the same time I'm not thinking about new shit yet.
I am thinking about wanting to do new shit,
but I'm also not like,
you know,
I don't want to fuck my own two are up by going to on the spot bombing people
go,
why would I go see that too?
Or he was shit when I saw him.
Well,
you're doing these giant fucking theaters and then you're also doing clubs.
Yeah.
I think that's so important.
And we were talking about that last night too,
that the intimacy of comedy clubs,
it's like you can't,
it can't get around.
It's the best environment for stand up.
Yeah.
It's like fucking prostitutes your whole life and then thinking you're making
love to a woman.
That's an interesting way of putting it.
Do you need a real woman to make love to this?
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
The comedy clubs.
A real woman.
Yeah.
Comedy clubs are overwhelming and if you're gay,
well you know,
then they're real man.
Whatever it is,
you're into a twink,
whatever,
whatever makes you happy.
They're not here to judge.
I'm just here to let you be happy.
Oh,
that's so sad.
Right?
Red Bands will be happy.
You playing with Tony last night,
by the way,
with some of the fun is when you called him out on the cable waste.
This was killed Tony,
the podcast,
and you guys did last night at the comedy store.
Yeah,
Russell was the gas.
It was a really fun episode.
Tony Tony was trying to do an impression of a gay guy and then went back to his
own voice and it was the exact same voice.
Tony was like,
hey,
so it's not right,
and I'm like,
dude,
that's the same voice.
You're gave voices your regular voice.
It's so funny.
Poor Tony Hinchcliffe.
It's not easy being narrow.
He looks like one of those movies from the 60s.
Remember when everybody was long scanning?
Yeah.
Like Gene Kelly,
you know,
he,
he's got a pill.
He's the only guy who can slip between an elevator.
Right.
This is about the end.
Indiana Jones is grabbing his hat and,
and Tony could just fly through it too.
He's got a bit about,
uh,
someone giving them an insult and telling them that he looks like a guy with
sleeping hat on,
which is the perfect fucking like he could see one of those guys were like a
kabod crane type dudes from back when no one got any nutrients.
Yeah.
Back Day,
those fucking dudes,
they didn't get any food.
People were tiny shit,
man.
Know,
like the average person
during World War three or not world war three,
uh,
during the civil war was like 120 535 pounds.
That was the average man.
We would have been fucking giant SPEC.
My God,
it was smashed.
Everybody would be ridiculous,
but could a humanity number heavyweight spec and the,
they were like 160 870 pounds.
I'm a rocky Marciano one 81 80 pounds,
180 make eight maybe.
And this prime at his heaviest,
you know,
and he was only five,
10.
That was the heavyweight champion of the world.
Yep.
Now we've got six,
six Vladimir Klitschko,
massive human super athlete.
That's why they're there.
That's why I'm even the Olympics have super heavyweight,
right.
They should have done in the UFC,
like Brock Lesnar's making a come back to the UFC and uh,
he's,
you know,
he's well over 300 pounds and he has to cut weight to get down to two 65.
Why does he have to be to 65 I don't know,
man.
Look,
I don't even know if he's really coming back to the UFC,
but that's what all the rumors are all over online.
They're talking about Brock losing weight to get to the UFC.
Don Frye was shitting on it the other day.
Don Probably shitting on block.
Brock Lesnar,
Brock Lesnar and cm punk and all that stuff.
I don't know.
He could shit on Brock Lesnar.
Brock Lesnar won the title.
You can be calling them a,
what'd you call him?
A little blond fairy.
Whoa.
He's fucking crazy.
Yeah.
I don't know if a Brock really is going to come back,
but if he does that'll be so exciting.
But I think they should have a super heavyweight.
They should don't shovel.
They just have a women's one 45 additional several women's.
Uh,
there's a,
um,
there's a mid weight between what?
W W what are the one 15 one 25 and then they have Bantam weight obviously.
So then they have two weight classes right now.
There needs to be something in between those two.
Yeah,
I agree.
I think it would at one 20 or something.
I think it'd be one 25 I don't think would be one 15 one 25 one 35 and hopefully
one 45.
They need to get Cyborg in the UFC before a prime is out.
You know,
she's still in her battery's dying.
Yeah.
Before it all ends.
He should also have an overweight class,
like the old days like that.
The big fat,
what does that big tank Abbott?
Yeah,
Tammy manual.
Yarborough.
And then just the big overweight or UFC,
he fought below to 65,
but I think um,
the uh,
a super heavyweight would be to 65 and above because it's kind of weird that you
have to lose weight for a heavyweight fight.
Did you don't,
yeah.
You think the whole,
the whole purpose of being a heavyweight to so you don't have to lose wight.
Yeah.
And this isn't the whole purpose of being a heavyweight is that you're the
biggest guy in the world.
Like you're,
you're the biggest,
strongest man.
Yeah.
So like I think it should be like two 65 and above that,
that's what makes sense to me.
A super heavyweight.
That'd be,
yeah,
that'd be good for Overeem.
Cause then they could decide where he wants to be.
He can't do that though.
He's the only way he's ever going to be able to fight that heavy as if he juices
and set again.
Allegedly didn't they used to have that way class though?
Huge.
Then they never had that weight class.
They just didn't have weight classes.
So when they started imposing weight classes,
there wasn't really enough talent at two 65 above two 65 for them to justify
having a super heavyweight cause you have like,
so let's say if you have a super heavyweight and you have some just giant Slob
who is like mediocre,
but he's big enough to fight it super heavy,
he becomes your champion and it's like that's not good.
Like you want to have like what's his name?
They're fucking,
I can picture him to want to just got knocked out.
Who has never been knocked up before?
Fat Heavyweight UFC guy.
His name's not coming to mullet.
Mullet.
He Burger King fucking,
oh,
I'm talking.
Oh Roy Nelson.
Nelson Nelson.
Yeah,
Roy.
He really should be fighting at two oh five or you know,
he might,
I mean if he got really lean fuck,
he might even be able to make one 85 because he's weighing like,
you know,
two 50 to 60 and he's got that big giant gut.
Yeah.
If you just lost that gut and all that excess fat,
I think,
I think he would get knocked out again.
Then a lot of using scented that.
Yeah.
Do you think he protects him being overweight?
I think it does.
And what keeps guys out a little bit.
It's hard.
You know,
it's hard to,
how do you shoot on a guy who's fucking gut is the first thing you're going to
hit?
It's probably a hard gut too.
Yeah,
it's a big man.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
He likes his food,
you know,
I'm not mad at him for it.
I was shocked when he got knocked out though.
I wasn't shocked because he was fighting hunt and the hunt is so slick.
He's so slick.
I mean he's been beaten by junior beat him and now we're doing beat him.
But when it comes skilled,
a skilled hunt,
first of all,
he's 40 years old and uh,
you know,
he's fought for decades.
My heart Mark Hunt forever.
I remember him in pride and yeah,
so he's going to have some losses.
He's always going to,
some guys are going to beat him and you know,
we're doing beat him in a brilliant performance.
But when,
when he's on and smooth and you're striking with him,
but you can't keep that rhythm,
he'll fuck you up.
You know,
he,
he did it to check Congo.
Congo had the chin of a fucking,
he could,
it was crystal had been its wars.
A lot of those guys,
you know,
by the time they get to the UFC or by the time they get to major,
uh,
that's like what happened with the cro cop.
You know,
you're right.
We're in a pride and he was so fucking dominant.
And then it wasn't the same guy.
It's fighting kickboxing or is he fighting MMA?
I think he's fighting MMA on New Year's.
He's finding he,
she,
the Olympic gold medalist in judo.
Each,
she's had a few,
uh,
MMA fights.
He fought fade or got knocked out by fate or I want to fade ours last fights.
The face.
Wasn't somebody trying to taunt fade or attempt fade or to come back?
Yeah,
the Bella tour,
which is the UFC,
he's um,
um,
like nemesis.
Well,
competition.
And they're there with Viacom,
you know,
so it's,
they have fucking billions dollars profit with them.
They might come up with some Russian oligarch type money if cause if they bought
out,
we're thinking if they bought out fader and then they outbid the UFC to get
Brock Lesnar,
Brock Lesnar versus fader and Bella tour federal would kill them.
You think so?
Yeah.
No matter how old fade or it's faders a fucking animal he prime.
I would s I would agree with you,
but I think they're both out of their prime now.
Which would make what?
What would make it interesting and with experience behind them and all that,
you know,
most likely I agree with you.
The variables are Brock Lesnar.
How much has he been training in this time off?
How motivated is he to actually make come back?
Cause it's something that's been eating away at him or is this just a bunch of
bullshit rumors?
I mean I haven't talked to him.
I haven't talked to Dana.
All I'm doing is reading shit on the Internet.
Yeah.
I try not to talk to Dana about this kind of stuff unless it's in person,
you know.
So I'll find out this weekend.
And I didn't tell the new people shit just pulled me aside and whisper.
But if it is true,
um,
you got to wonder what is the motivation?
Like how much is he just thinking,
I don't want to wrestle anymore.
Or does he have this like this burning desire to try on and stick thing?
I think he doesn't have as much money as he thought he'd have right now.
You think?
And it's like,
you know what?
One more fight.
Nice paycheck.
I'll sit out after that.
Maybe.
Why also no bills to pay.
You know,
he feels that that diverticulitis that he had,
whether he had 12 inches of his colon removed,
yeah.
He feels that that was a huge limiting factor.
And they never fought 100% that,
I mean,
you know,
that's what you can eat seeds and,
and stuff like that.
That's what,
that's what it,
is that a diverticulitis and be when it's healing?
No.
That's what causes it.
That's what triggers it.
Sometimes seeds can do it,
right?
Yeah.
Cause it,
where's it stuck?
It gets stuck in eat and somehow,
you know,
perforates your uh,
your intestines and stuff.
Like there's apparently there's a bunch of causes for it.
The other ones are you can get developed abscesses if you eat too much protein
and not enough fiber.
That's true.
People get backed up and it sticks there.
And that's apparently Lesnar.
Couldn't you see Lesnar taking giant bites of meat and not even chewing them?
Just throwing them down like an alligator.
You know,
like if shit ever seen the allergist to show off,
take chunks of meat and just gobble it down.
Well that stuff gets,
you know what I want to try is that you've,
you've hunted wild pig.
Yeah.
I really want to taste some of that while I am.
I brought some in for him.
Yeah.
My Dad used to tell me about it,
smoke it,
put it on the smoker.
Oh,
so good.
My Dad used to eat wild boar in India and he was like,
Oh man,
that shit was,
he goes,
it's better than any pork you've ever eaten in your life.
What's a different color?
It's weird.
Yeah,
but he says so delicious.
So tasty.
You get pig from the supermarket and it's like this pinkish.
I mean,
remember they were saying pork,
the other white meat.
Remember that and remember that it's not supposed to be white.
Like the pork that I have is now white at all.
Then when they're eating natural foods like acorns and stuff like that,
they developed this like dark skin.
That's like salmon.
When you buy salmon from the supermarket,
a lot of times if they don't die it,
it's Pale.
And so they,
they actually put dye in the flash to change to the code and we're going orange
too.
But that color that we're accustomed to is because of their diet.
It's because of the shrimp that they eat.
They eat the shrimp that makes their skin like an actual orange color,
and it's very similar to what happens with peacocks or not peacocks,
flamingos,
flamingos.
That pink color that flamingos
have comes from the bugs.
Eat not a trip.
I did not know this.
So when you see pork and the grocery store and it's that pale color,
that's some fucking prison pork,
that's important.
It's just like that,
that,
that wasn't a,
that was shanked to death.
That did you see that video?
I put it on Twitter a few days ago of a,
this guy used a drone to fly over these pork factories and find out what kind of
a fucking holocaust camp they're running there.
Right?
Oh,
it's fuck dude.
It's fucked.
They have these lakes,
I mean,
just literally lakes of urine and shit.
Toxic Lake every underneath these pigs.
It's like these grates and they shit and piss and it goes into this funnel and
it flows into this like artificial lake that they've created of shit and piss
and it's like right next to these houses with these pigs live just jammed and
next to each other.
I think I just quit eating pork.
I really do.
I think I quit eating pork.
Seen that.
I don't want to eat that.
I'm a fan of the pork.
It's delicious pork for me.
I need,
I think I need to go only wild pork.
They're smart man.
You know,
they're not dumb like cows.
No.
When you take pigs and stuff them in there like that,
like they're experiencing some,
some real torture ever.
See pigs being transported on the freeway.
It's depressing and they're passing like,
oh,
uh,
like they're passing Disneyland or something.
Do you think the pigs go,
hey,
fuck,
we're going to Disneyland guys.
If you believe in evolution and I know you don't,
I'm just kidding.
I'm a big proponent.
But if you believe in evolution and you think that,
I mean this,
it's just like,
you know,
not a real question.
Um,
but if you believe in evolution,
you think the things eventually,
like we,
at one point in time,
our ancient ancient ancestors were some sort of monkey,
right?
Or even before that,
some other mammal,
like I was listening to radio lab and they were,
they were,
uh,
talking about post,
post impact crater.
Like when the impact hit the Yucatan and killed all the dinosaurs.
Like what mammal survived.
That became that we became human beings eventually and it was like this weird
rodent thing and it was weird,
large burrowing rodent that managed to survive after the asteroid impact.
So that became a person who is on the Internet.
What if pigs get smart enough where they can start talking?
I mean with,
if we keep eating pigs for like the next couple thousand years and pigs just
slowly figured out only through mutation or selective breeding,
they're figuring out a way to manipulate their tongues.
The point where they can like express themselves.
Like,
please,
please let me out of here.
I'll kill a chicken for you.
I'll show you.
I'll show you where the cows sleeps.
Like,
come on man.
Don't,
don't,
don't do this.
Don't do this,
dude.
Don't do this.
So we're,
we need to wait for pigs to understand consequence.
Well,
we need to wait for pigs to express the fact that they don't want to be there.
Like,
we know the dolphins,
super smart,
but
we don't give a fuck if they complain,
we don't know him.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Do you want to fish oil?
You have to flip.
You know,
like,
we know they're smart.
Like they're like people smart.
Like dolphins are stupid.
Smart.
We don't give a fuck and compassionate.
Yes.
And they've never killed a person.
Dolphins save people there.
There was one sort of rogue dolphin killed a person.
Yeah,
I remember reading about this either last year or something.
I know killer whales have killed a bunch of that.
That's definite.
That's there.
It's in their name,
but there was like a rogue dolphin or so they killed someone.
Wow.
Dolphin kills people.
And the one with that pocket knife and then he was like on math or something.
Yeah.
The dark side of dolphins.
Dolphins attack humans.
Yeah.
They rape
dolphins or Brian red bands.
Well,
this is the hard thing.
They re bill Cosby of don't kill each other's babies.
It's the most fucked up thing about dolphins.
Hey,
everybody's got a vice Joe doll.
Dolphins really are assholes.
They're famous for killing a killing their own babies,
you know,
and not there.
It's what someone else's,
the dolphin became infamous for killing a swimmer.
Wow.
30 people were attacked by this one.
Dolphin kick.
Wow.
So this is like some like super aggressive dolphin.
His name is t I a.
O.
T.
I o was a female.
So for solitary female Bluenose dolphin that resided in a town in Brazil,
the dolphin became famous for killing a swimmer and injuring many others.
Wow.
Kill the swimmer.
I she kill swimmer.
Carberry held him down.
Came up,
snowed at him.
Oh,
she,
she killed a drunk,
you know,
they were harassing the Dolphin.
Oh,
well,
there you go.
There was two people that were,
hello harassment dolphin.
One guy's name was Wilson and the woman's name was Zhao and um,
they were harassing and possibly attempting to restrain the dolphin.
The Dolphin broke the ribs of Wilson and killed Zhao who was later found to be
drunk after this incident.
The dolphin briefly left,
but returned to the beach.
Well,
this is a wild dolphin too.
That's interesting,
man.
Well,
they were assholes.
They were assholes and they were fucking wrestling with this dolphin and don't
fuck with animals.
This drunk bitch died.
That's what happened.
I just bought a new book that I highly recommend about dolphins.
It's called wet goddess,
but it's available on Amazon.
It's about a relationship is the only person in the 50 shades of grey for
dolphins.
Yeah,
it really is.
Did you actually read it?
No,
I haven't read it yet.
I just got it just delivered today.
But it's,
it's uh,
here.
It's what got us,
but it's a,
yeah,
I bought two of them.
You can never have too many,
but I like the cover.
It's just like,
it's kind like a scrapbook with a adults.
Why did you buy two?
Why did you buy too?
I just feel like it's not going to be a for,
I don't know.
It's not going to be around for the way you're holding onto it.
You're going to be a hoarder from dolphin porn.
Well,
look at this.
I mean like they're used,
they're going for $61.
Yeah.
See,
I think there's a big mark.
Oh look,
this 1,900 wives.
Fuck.
How was that?
Is that probably not all paperback?
That's gotta be the hard copy.
That's to actually get the dolphin to fuck you.
A code code underground.
Fucking wrote about,
look at a spout on that dolphin.
You just buy the book and inside the book,
it's just directions to this place in San Diego.
That's one of the weird things about people when it comes to stuff like,
like a dolphin
porn or something like that.
You would think,
well,
who the fuck would be into that?
And then you put it online and it attracts a whole community.
And the next thing you know is a message board all filled with people that are
talking about their dolphin porn and the Dolphin love and their kinship of you.
If you've heard about that.
Some people,
they don't want to be judged by being akin to certain animals.
They feel like their Fox kin,
like they feel connected to a Fox.
I don't,
I,
I can't,
uh,
I can sort of understand to a certain degree.
I did this movie a few years ago and I had to ride an elephant in it.
And when I was standing there with the elephant,
the way the elephant was looking at me and I was looking at her,
I really felt like,
I was like,
I really love you elephants.
Like I genuinely felt like,
I think I have a crush on this elephant.
Not in a sexual way.
More like,
I just want to hug you and love you.
Yeah.
Trainers have to fall in love with their animals a lot.
That's why I don't understand.
Beat them.
I'm like,
stop fucking hating him.
But that spiked fucking stick.
Yeah.
There are people that believe that they are akin like,
like they're somehow or another,
they should have been this animal instead of a person.
You know?
Some people think that they were born male,
but they really should have been a woman.
Yeah.
Some people think that they were born a person,
but they should have been an elephant or the shit that's,
that's a,
that's a little mental.
Is it though for you to judge?
I'm just saying people don't,
people don't understand there's a,
there's a whole tumbler blog about it.
Good Lord.
Did they try to manifest physically into these things?
Uh,
well some of those folks that are fluffy's are furries Hafiz.
Gabriel,
he's not
laughing.
Yeah.
Some of those people,
I'm sure that's what they're doing there.
They're wishing that they actually were some weird animal.
Yeah.
I think that's escapism.
What do you think?
I think a lot of what people do is escape is I'm including being into shit that
everybody just accepts,
like being in a dungeons and dragons.
That's escapism being into cosplay.
That's escapism.
Like at what point do we decide it's fucked up?
Like it's okay if you want to dress up and reenact the civil war.
Why is it fucked up?
If you want to pretend you're fox,
like you're not a soldier from 1800 you douchebag,
okay?
You're an asshole who wishes the south one and you're putting on some ancient
stuff and using a musket,
right?
That's what you're doing.
W you know why isn't it?
Why is that okay for you to pretend you were born Arrow with no internet for you
to pretend that you were born in the time where there's no cars.
That's okay,
but it's not okay to pretend you're a fox.
Hey,
see what I'm saying?
It's not okay to be a Fox.
You're live and let live love live and let die it yourself about
dat,
Dat,
da Da.
On the news today on the news today.
They found some hikers that went missing last night and the fucking idiot girl,
um,
did what they were like and she had no shoes on and then they're interviewing or
after and she's like,
well we can then we went to sleep last night and then I took my shoes off and
uh,
there was this box nearby and we're like,
what a cute Fox.
And I think the Fox stole my shoes.
Like,
you're in the fucking wilderness.
Keep your shoes on Asheville.
What are you trying to be respectful to the dirt that you're lying on?
I've got some drama at my house,
man.
When here hear some shit?
Oh,
I'm,
are you telling me this?
Last night a coyote ran off with one of my chickens.
I saw it.
I was,
this is what it's,
that's not even the most fucked up part of the story.
My Yard,
the way my yard is set up,
um,
well there's the back area and then there's this one acre,
like wooded lot.
It has trees is as huge place where my dogs hang out and they have the best
yard.
It's like this incredible yard's huge.
There was plenty of room for them to run around.
But the reality is,
you know when I'm at work or you know,
no one's home or you know,
maybe uh,
the dogs are inside because they want to be outside and playing.
They're by themselves for hours and hours at a time and I think they become
friends with a fucking coyote.
Sweet.
I think the coyote has weaseled his way into their friendship.
I think this,
cause this is,
my dogs are friendly dogs so I think what has happened is that coyote has gotten
close to them,
like stays in the outside of the fence.
They bark at him and he hangs out and he doesn't show any fear.
And then eventually Kim's closed and they like,
you know,
they like come close to each other and maybe he even goes in there and hangs out
with them.
I don't know cause coyotes can jump fences like crazy.
I've watched him do it.
It's amazing.
Like,
I watched him jump the fence with a chicken in his mouth and I was like,
Whoa,
these motherfuckers are,
they're just not like dog.
They're Wiley.
They're so smart.
So anyway,
um,
what I think happened,
here's,
so here's the story.
I see this fucking Fox or the coyote rather.
I see him running with the chicken in his mouth while I'm playing uno with my
daughters,
right?
We're playing cards and I'm looking out the window.
I'll go,
I'll fucking,
God is grabbing a chicken.
I run the dog.
Oh,
hey,
he doesn't give a fuck.
They don't got that chicken.
He's good.
And he's going to eat a whole chicken,
a full grown chicken.
He's psyched,
right?
That's a meal and a half or a coyote.
And he jumps over the fence and then I run out to get them.
And then I hear my wife scream,
the fucking dog is over here with a chicken in its mouth.
I'm like,
what?
The dog had gotten out of his side of the yard gun over to where the coyote was
and helped the coyote.
Oh,
he wasn't barking at the coyote.
He wasn't upset.
The coyote was there.
The coyote ran off of the chicken and Johnny had a chicken in his mouth.
John's a good guy.
You another one.
I could,
I couldn't fucking believe it.
I was like,
you've gotta be careful now because I'm coyotes are friending up your dog to uh,
to eat it.
Yeah.
Well,
he's huge.
He's 140 pounds.
They're still going.
They're going to get a group of them together.
And I'm like,
listen guys,
I know we're going to have a feast.
That's,
I didn't take a lot of work.
You should get some trail cams going on.
And well,
dude,
death is uncommon.
It's going to happen.
There's going to be some destruction in my yard.
But,
uh,
the,
the point being like,
I,
it took me a while to figure out what happened.
I had to figure out how he got out.
And the way he got out was there's two fences and one fence has this latch that
was open.
Then he got to the second one.
The second one has this weird door where if you like wiggle it,
the latch pops up.
And he could just go through and he,
he knows how to do that and he's pretty smart.
So he wiggles that door.
He showed me how he got through and like,
oh you motherfucker.
And then I followed him and I'm not even mad at him because I just feel like he
just made a friend,
you know it's fucked up.
Could potentially having killed.
It's possible he just made friends with a gang member.
Yeah,
it is definitely possible.
If he was a small dog I'd be way more terrified.
No Daddy t-bones my friend,
he's an enormous dog.
But what is he?
He's a master for regency.
Massive half pit bull.
Half Neapolitan.
Massive.
They're big dogs but don't remember,
did I meet his a big sweetie?
He's a very,
very nice dog.
But he killed a chicken.
Can you step up your chicken chicken fence game?
Like it's going to be,
have to be more than that.
It doesn't matter cause coyotes can get over like ridiculous fences.
Like they,
they do weird shit.
Like first of all they figure out where there's high spots in the ground and
they bounced to the high spot.
And then over the fence I've watched him leave,
or like the park who are animals,
they really are the way he left.
Um,
there was a statue in my backyard and he leaped up,
put his feet on the statute and then over the fence and he did it like he's done
it a thousand times,
which you probably has.
So I realized that it's almost like a vampire sneaking out of your daughter's
window in the middle of the night.
You're like,
oh,
okay,
we got a problem here.
Like this motherfucker has become friends with my dog.
You need to set up a trap and hunt that motherfucker.
Right?
Yeah.
We've got to figure out something to do because the dogs are at least in
somewhat danger because he will eat them.
I mean,
whether or not he thinks they're his friends or he cons them and thinking
they're his friends.
The coyote knows he's wild and he knows those are pets.
He,
it's probably just too much danger to try to attack the dog by himself.
You know when you have a big giant dog of the big head like that dog,
it's just too much power.
Now.
All of us to do is bite you.
It breaks your leg and your maimed and even if you get away,
you probably won't be able to catch anything and eat it.
You'll starve to death.
Dogs and coyotes are totally different animals.
Coyotes are acutely aware of the danger involved in any altercations,
so they're very Wiley.
They very sneaky and how they set things up,
but I'm almost positive that this dog and my coyote,
the coyote,
coyote,
and my dog are friends,
which is really fucked.
Are you allowed to hunt coyote?
Is that legal?
I do not know.
I don't know if you can hunt them,
but can you just kill one,
right?
Yeah,
I think what?
Well,
okay,
look around.
Is it a little bit,
let's say one of the laws for killing coyotes in California,
not do you have a silencer?
We can't talk about this on the Internet and by silence or I mean somebody who
just tells you to be quick think I'm probably going to do is hire someone to
deal with it because uh,
the road runner,
this is probably like organizations that,
that do it,
you know,
I guess hire a couple of doors,
pizza on the couch.
Well they have problems with that all the time with pets.
Like they have coyotes that come into neighborhoods and start killing a ton of
pants.
Like we were talking about this,
there was a retirement community in this retirement community.
They had some ungodly numbers in Arizona.
There was like 30 attacks one year on pets by coyotes where people were walking
the pets.
They realize that these people were old and they,
they can't walk so good and they just like free lunch and they just run up to
him and steal their dog.
It's,
it's also scary just the fact that there is a coyote in your yard and if your
daughter's outside playing and there's this crazy coyote with rabies and shit,
well they will not even rabies.
They just see something small and they're in if they're really hot.
Well my daughter's never by themselves.
Totally.
But you gotta be careful.
There was a five year old kid that was attacked in big bear just last year.
His fucking,
his dad had a poll,
the coyote off of them.
The coyote had bit the kid's leg.
It was trying to take them down five-year-old.
Yeah.
Fuck that dude.
I sit there and pretty bad in Burbank also,
but I have such a high fence.
I don't even think there's a,
I hear,
I hear them and there's a huge pack of in my near my house and one night I was
standing on the balcony at night and I could hear them,
you know,
making all their fucking noise.
And then I heard a dog barking and here are from then I here and then
silence.
It was just quiet.
Dead ass quiet.
Yeah,
I dunno.
We'd have to figure out what the laws are.
That'd be real care if my neighbor has horses.
Ooh.
So I don't think they're going to mess with the horse.
So much.
Horses too big.
All they'd have to do is get kicked by that horse.
The horse will kill him.
Yeah.
I had a dog get his foot broken by a horse.
He was just too curious and the horse wants stomp to stomp down on his foot.
Your thought about getting a horse,
Joe?
No,
I'm not into horses.
Pony for the babies.
I would like to,
I mean I like horses,
like to look at and pet them,
but I'm not in a riding animals at all and I'm like,
we have cars.
This is stupid.
I'm just like,
I'm not into this relationship or my,
rub it on your back and your carry me over.
I rode a horse once when I was like 13 and I remember how much my balls hurt and
they were brand new then.
Your balls
did not tell balls.
They are today.
The beatings that they've taken now they can hang on you on either side of the
pony or a horse.
Okay,
so there's a,
there's an article on coyote removal in suburban areas.
Hmm.
Interesting.
Coyote removal and suburban areas.
Once coyotes have lost their fear of humans or have started behaving
aggressively at health and safety.
Hazard exists.
Usually it can be remedied only by the removal of one or two or more,
one or more of the coyotes.
Typical typically coyote removal in urban or suburban areas conducted by
Predator control.
Professionals who shoot coyotes are captured them and padded leghold traps or
snares.
So I've got to hire somebody captured.
Coyotes must be destroyed as relocating problem coyotes would incur unacceptable
liability and risk on the part of the agency involved.
And relocation is illegal without prior approval of the California Department of
fish and game.
So you have to kill them.
No problem with that.
Fuck,
I wonder what the,
what is the law though?
I hope nobody from pitas listening.
I don't think,
well listen man,
if they are pita,
you kill a lot of fucking cats and dogs every year.
Can you eat coyotes kid get the truth and you can't eat them.
They are gross and they most likely have diseases.
You have to cook the shit out of it.
But Steve Nela cooked and ate a coyote.
Could pull that video up.
It's pretty fucked up.
Steve Rinella.
How did,
how did he say coyote?
Uh,
he said it was like diver duck,
which doesn't really help me.
That is know me either.
Yeah.
Gamie is the only one we understand.
Gamie is,
uh,
usually it's just the way they treat it.
It's like,
or the way they,
uh,
rather,
um,
uh,
process the meat from killing it to actually eating it is like a,
it allows to it to get spoiled or warm or the tarsal gland from the animal.
It can get like certain animals,
especially when they're in heat.
Like a lot of times if you get deer,
you're getting deer in there.
Yeah.
This is a coyote.
They're burning it on the,
uh,
the fire.
You can,
they won't pull us from Youtube.
You could play this.
Okay.
It's already on youtube.
No.
Yeah,
but we get pulled from youtube all the time for shit.
But this would only be a,
yeah.
Vexing question.
That's a coyote cow.
Our coyote is as perfectly cooked as it's ever going to get.
All that's left to do is to dig.
That's real nice.
All right.
It doesn't look bad.
Well,
let's meet,
you know what I mean?
It's well seasoned.
I just got the taste of what a coyote smells like.
It's fatty.
I mean it's like dry fatty.
I Dunno.
I like that.
Yeah,
like it's rich.
Like dry Turkey lane,
whereas like dry but still got that dark meat.
Three iot.
This is so weird.
I'll tell you one day you made sloppy joes or this or you could make a pulled
pork with this with barbecue sauce.
You would never ever,
ever.
No.
Wow,
that's great.
I think everything tastes better with barbecue sauce.
Oh God.
There's a website called pita kills animals and Peta has killed more than 33
animals since (990) 830-3030 3033 is not really a high number.
Yeah,
sorry.
33,000 animals since 1998 these are dogs at p to euthanize and discarded in a
North Carolina dumpster.
Whoa.
How was that?
Oh my God.
There's the photographs.
Yes.
Oh,
this is so fucked.
Yeah.
Why?
I think there's like they run out of resources like they don't know.
Um,
well there's a report about how many,
the vast pita swiftly kills the vast majority of the dogs and cats and it's
care.
Wow.
Yeah.
It seems like you could just put a couple a motion detector,
trail cams then run out and like get your bow and just shoot it in the detector
goes off.
Yeah.
But you gotta be careful about the legality of it,
of like shooting a weapon in an urban or suburban area.
That's what their fear is.
That you'll miss the shoot a human.
Yeah.
Well you are you,
yeah,
you could definitely hit something else if you miss,
you're not supposed to do that.
You've got to get a trap.
I'm just going to hire somebody.
I want to fucking go out Indiana Jones on this coyote Rambo side in the tree.
Plus I don't want to get fucking invested in this thing and that weird way.
There's gotta be some sort of coyote removal service that's an expert,
but an electrical fence with a light mild current to that.
Cause I have kids and I have chickens and I have,
there's all sorts of stuff going on.
Have you been there for the chickens and the chickens freaking out like they're
not happy.
There's two of them are dead cow and the other ones have to be far freaked
because they saw it happen probably and now my dog is fucking public enemy
number one.
And then my wife was super mad at him too.
She loves the chickens.
Get your eggs from him.
It's just weird that he didn't even bark at the coyote.
He just ran over there and was hanging out with him.
That's his buddy.
What's like a wolf?
Right?
They're just smarter shit.
Who Was it last night?
Was it rent as easy?
That was telling us the story of the coyote had a fake limp.
Like these coyotes were walking in front of this,
this area with a fake limp and a nose.
The Sklar brothers,
Sklar brothers Coyote is walking in front of his dog with a fake limp and the
dogs barking and running up to the fence,
Blah Blah.
And the guy goes out to grab his dog to stop it,
sees the coyote there and looks down at the end of the driveway and there's
eight other coyotes waiting.
So with this coyote was going to do Beetham like pretend it's limping.
Like they walk like they're limping.
The dog comes out to chase them.
They were down on the other [inaudible]
Gang Bang them.
Fuck.
That's what I'm saying.
That's why I'm worried for your dog.
It's possible.
But he seems to be buddies with him.
Like he's not trying to kill anybody.
He's trying to show him chickens are,
it's kind of how they friend them,
you know.
I'm sure.
Look,
if they could,
they would eat them.
But like I said,
he,
I have another dog.
They'll,
they'll kill for sure.
He's small.
He's only like 40 pounds or 50 at the most.
How big is Brutus?
You think?
50 pounds.
80 pounds.
And he's not big at all like that.
His name's Brutus.
Yeah,
he's,
his name is Mr Booboo.
That's what I call,
she's still limping or is he off fix,
get well,
he's got arthritis.
Those,
uh,
a lot of those weird breeds like a English bulldogs with those crazy phases.
Those dogs,
man,
they breathed the shit out of him and they breed them to the point with like a
good majority of them have health issues.
Like a lot of them have problems with their noses.
They,
a lot of them have problems breathing.
A lot of them have problems with their hips.
They have like arthritis issues and he's half Sheebu he knew.
So he's probably better off than some of them are cause he's got a little less
Shiba ina with them,
which is like a sort of a pretty agile little dog.
But you know,
poor little guy.
But he just laid around all day and chills.
Just sweet dog.
They'll fuck him up though.
That's a different that he can't even kill a chicken.
The chicken.
Fuck him Johnny Cash
shitting in the little in June.
Well,
I used to have a dog named Frank Sinatra.
I had another dog named squeaky Fromme
and uh,
this is,
uh,
he's Johnny Cash to my favorite though.
He's the best.
He's so sweet.
How old is he?
He's a eight.
It's like it's getting up there for a big dog for sure.
They don't start getting kidney problems.
No.
Do you have any hip or knee?
He's got a little bit of arthritis,
but you put fish oil in his diet and it helps that up quite a bit.
Officialism amazing anti-inflammatory man.
He put that in their diet.
Keep them away from grain based diets.
That's,
that's big too.
Like a lot of those,
a lot of those dog foods that you buy,
they're cheap.
They have a lot of filler in them that fucks with dogs that have arthritis.
You know,
people are very similar in a lot of ways.
Like there's certain foods that cause inflammation in people and same thing with
dogs.
But I find that fish oil,
it makes a difference.
I give them fish oil squeak,
get it from the grocery store or the pet food store and you squirt it on their
food.
Yeah.
You got dogs?
No,
I have no pets.
that's nice.
You could have fucking crazy parties.
You don't have to worry about anybody getting,
have a daughter.
That's it.
She has a cat.
She,
her and my ex wife have a little cat.
Oh,
I just got a new kitten.
I actually really like Kay.
Well I got it for my daughter cause you know my daughter broke her arm.
Which one?
Which daughter?
The six year old and she broke her arm and um,
she was a at school and doing the monkey bars,
which is how I broke my arm in the exact same age.
And uh,
she's a little girl.
She was so sad and she you to wear a cast and we said when you get your cast off
we'll get your kit.
And she gave her like this thing to look forward to.
Did you get to get particular breed or just another rag doll?
I love those rag dolls there for like a house cat.
They're the best.
They're so sweet.
Like you pick them up,
they just start purring.
They go limp on you.
They're just like always want to be around.
Yeah.
My daughter's cat purr,
like loves my daughter,
like just follows around everywhere she goes.
When you see any picture of my daughter sleeping,
the cat's right beside her at all times.
One Paul on her just to make sure she doesn't go anywhere.
It's pretty cool.
That's adorable.
But then will bite her at all times because my daughter will just fuck with it.
Yeah.
My cat scratch the shit out of my four year old this morning.
She was a pig.
Well they pick her up like she's a stuffed animal and the four year old doesn't
get it.
The six year old gets it.
But the four year old like things like this is fucking,
I'll do whatever I want with you.
You can put this little nubbies on their claws.
Yeah.
They have like these little rubber.
Yeah,
I have that on spazz on the old cat.
She's,
she doesn't have much time left man.
My oldest cat is 18 she's almost 19 Jesus,
she'll be 19 in like a few months.
She can go drink in Canada.
Is that 18 that you drank 10 and 19 Canada's so much better in that way.
That's so smart.
You're going to pretend kids aren't gonna drink at 18 I could be done.
It is a very ridiculously,
um,
that governed law,
that one in America,
that 21 year old drinking age.
I think it really puzzles the shit out of me.
I would rather have 18 year old drinkers and 21 year old drivers.
Uh Yeah.
Or 21 year old gun owners and 18 year olds.
Yeah.
I would really like,
I'm way more concerned with you being an idiot driving a car than I am with you
being an idiot.
Just driving or just drinking.
Right.
So if you're getting like 18 year old kids,
a lot of them have to have jobs obviously.
So this is,
you know,
it fucks them up if they need to drive.
But I think that I'm more concerned with them driving a fucking car at 16 and
drinking illegally than I am with them.
You know,
just just being able to drink at eight
16 year old girl on the highway,
texting,
driving,
watch this
senior old boy the other day,
weaving in and out of lanes and I thought it was hammered and I got next to him
and looked at his car and he's just sitting there like this while he's driving,
texting,
trying to get some pussy.
It's late at night,
you know,
trying to Texas girlfriend just sneak out the window trying to meet her in the
fucking,
meet her in the swing set and swing set.
Meet you at the monkey bars.
Break up.
I mean,
how many parents are just fucking take an ambiance at night to go to sleep and a
kid's just sneaking out getting Dick or given it I've given Dick or get an end
given dick.
Yeah,
I was lucky I was allowed to sleep over at my girlfriend's house at a different
school district at the age of 1615 and her dad would come in and he's like,
yeah,
her dad would come and wake us up.
It'd be like a burden.
You've got to wake up cause I have to wake up earlier.
You were being bed together?
Yeah.
It would be laying in bed together.
Your mouth.
Yeah.
It was weird.
It was really weird.
Oh,
Maria fucking too.
Oh yeah,
we were fucking,
she's the one that had my first threesome with that girl.
I think the whole family was just very freaky for his liberal and then there's
just eh,
fuck it.
Yeah,
but he,
that dad,
the guy,
the dad that would wake us up.
He's one of the richest guys in the United States.
Is He really?
Yeah.
Warren Buffett's kid.
Good deal.
What happened?
How'd you,
how'd you fucked that up?
I don't remember.
Oh,
after the threesome it fucked everything up.
Oh ways.
Yeah.
Whenever I hear about that,
I hear you're going to have a threesome with two chicks.
You don't really know.
Yeah.
Now you're talking.
A friend of mine said that to me.
It can't be emotional for us going to let them have threesomes and I said I had
a joke about it that like having a friend come up to you and tell you that he's
about to have threesomes is like having a friend come up to you and tell you
that he's starting to make his own bombs like,
oh,
that's going to blow up in your face.
Yeah.
You can't have,
even if your girl is trying to be cool,
hey,
why don't we think about bringing,
nope,
let's not think about that.
Leave that to the fucking whores that want to do that or the professionals.
Yeah,
four hands.
It's the emotions involved there.
They can't handle it.
That meant it's,
it sounds good on paper to them.
I have a friend that was dating a girl while they were dating in the beginning.
They weren't very serious.
Had a threesome together with his friend and then kept dating and then
eventually got married and got closer and closer and like,
you know,
like became like a serious item and I go,
how do you get over the fact that your friend was fucking her mouth while you
were banging it from behind?
Like this is what you guys did.
And he goes,
I just,
it just is,
it is.
I mean he was laughing what he was talking about.
He had a racist term.
Your head just is,
it's as good friend.
But I mean the friend was over the house and I was,
I watched the interaction,
you know,
like the friend,
like I was over and uh,
you know,
he's there with his wife and a friend came over and she hugs the friend and he
hugs the friend.
I'm like,
Yo,
Ho Ho and a bottle of rum.
Hey Man,
you know,
memories.
I guess they weren't,
I guess time heals,
but is it a pain?
Well,
how long,
what was the time difference?
I mean years and years.
That's enough time.
Eight or nine years.
But time you get over it,
but it's not just the,
it's like time heals.
If there's a wound,
there's a wound for you.
But is there a wound for him?
Like that's the question.
He's got that smirk the whole time.
Maybe,
you know,
he doesn't,
maybe it doesn't care.
Maybe neither one of them earlier that attached to it.
Well maybe it's one of those things like when people become swingers,
you know,
which is way more common than you would think.
There are a lot of people that have agreements with their significant other and
they both go out and bang other people I know love them.
It's a very logical situation.
It's pragmatic in some ways.
Like,
hey listen,
we're both retarded.
We're not going to keep this together,
so let's just make it a little,
but that always falls apart too.
Yeah.
I think,
I think it should happen where they don't see it happen.
You know?
It's better to tell.
No you,
I mean you can,
you know,
listen,
I've got something to do.
I think you have a code.
You know,
I got some to do tonight.
I'll see you later.
Well,
we have a friend that was involved in an open marriage and his wife would come
home and she would talk about all the guys.
She was fucking and he liked it.
Yeah.
I mean if that's your look
fried chicken and said that was weird.
Right?
Yeah.
Cause we knew him before that,
which really crazy is we knew him before that and he had a bad breakup and when,
when he had the bad breakup but the kid was devastated.
He wanted to get her back,
but she wouldn't take him back and he didn't know what to do.
And you know,
I should kind of gave me some advice.
I'm like,
look it,
you just got a deal.
I mean this is just,
do you love her?
And he goes,
yeah.
And I go,
well if you love her,
you've got to want her to be happy.
And if her being happy means her not having sex with you,
that's just reality.
Like you have to accept that that's reality.
Like there's a lot of people out there that you don't have sex with.
Right.
And it just because you,
I mean,
because you haven't had sex with him in the past,
it doesn't drive you nuts that you can't have sex with them now.
Right.
So you're just connecting yourself to the relationship that you two used to have
and that's the only,
like he won't love her in any other way.
You need that,
those parameters in order for you to care about her as a person.
He's like,
I just can't do it.
I can't be her friend.
I'm like,
that's so crazy.
He goes,
I can't help it.
I'm jealous.
I'm just,
I'm just too jealous.
I can't do it.
It's like,
okay.
But then right after that,
he's involved in a fucking open marriage.
His next relationship,
he went one 80 he said just she's,
she's a whore.
Like he would talk about her being a whore.
Like he loved it and loved.
Aw,
she's so horny.
It's lovely still fucker too.
Now they broke up.
Oh,
it didn't work,
but for a while that worked shit for a while.
He was happy.
It was weird.
It was crazy.
It was just like,
he tried to not like it.
He didn't like being a democrat.
Fuck it.
I'm going to be a Republican.
We just,
we just took,
went total the other way,
he went from being like the super jealous,
like I can't be friends with my ex and les were boyfriend,
girlfriend.
That's it.
To fucking,
I'm going to just date a swinger.
Like she would go out with guys,
I'm going on a date tonight.
Democrats are swingers.
And he didn't know,
I'm just a bad example.
I should have said like dolphins fan or Raiders fans.
It's basically the same thing.
But he,
he would go out and he would,
uh,
you know,
he would like call you fucking this guy right now.
And she'd be like,
Yup.
And like he would like get excited about it.
What do jerk off?
I,
I mean I've banged a swinger,
uh,
in front of his wife,
Oh,
sorry.
In front of,
in front of him.
In front of him.
That dude,
let me rephrase.
Do you bang the wife?
The husband was watching.
Why would you want that?
I didn't want I,
but he was like,
it was an l shaped couch and he sat in one corner.
I said,
just don't fucking touch me.
Don't fucking,
don't touch me.
You stay over there and I'll fuck your wife.
But did you,
what if he went,
I've got to go to the bathroom.
He came back and he felt something,
touch your balls.
I would probably turn around and kill the motherfucker,
but you're fucking his wife.
It seems rude to kill him when I get,
I'll tell you the funny story.
I was,
we were there at their house.
It was me and Vernon,
my buddy,
uh,
I don't say any names.
Yeah,
my buddy,
he passed away.
But uh,
we're sitting there on couch l shaped couch and she just start leans over and
starts blowing me.
Oh boy.
And then my friends sitting beside me and beside her and he's,
he's just like,
you know,
she's blown me.
And then the husband and my friend just staring at each other cause the way on
the other side.
And my friend just does this like,
hey,
is that,
is that okay?
Can I,
can I get some of this as two from her and the husband?
She goes,
yeah,
go ahead.
Wait.
So the husband says,
yeah,
you can fuck my life too.
So two guys are drilling so,
so I'm sitting there,
she's blowing,
she's blowing me.
And then my friend starts fingering her from behind and uh,
and I'm like,
all right,
as long as we're,
nobody's fucking touching me,
I'm good at just as long as it's just women on me,
I'm good.
Is this guy beaten off or anything?
The husbands in the corner just stroking it
far enough away that he can't come on you.
You Google like what's the longest,
the longest distance the guys ever call it really an l shaped couch.
And we're at the short part of the L.
He's at the fucking far long part of the l I think the world record for shooting
a load.
It's like three feet.
The guy like shot hit my foot.
Was that Peter Number three feet like three like 12 inches.
12 inches.
Well,
I dunno,
it might've been Peter North.
I don't know who's the fall I shot over.
Girls hadn't hit the wall.
Whoa.
You might've be the world record holder.
I don't know.
But it was,
and that was impressive.
It was funny because I was in my twenties and I shut,
it was my friend's house.
I'm banging this broad.
He walks in and as you walk in,
the bed was right there and I'm behind her and he goes,
I go,
hey,
can you come back?
And he goes,
yeah.
So he leaves.
I pull out I nut and not on her back.
I not on the wall.
Some of it hits his pill.
I just flipped his pillow over
the jellies.
Use your sleeve to rub it out there.
Just kind of flipped it over and giggled to myself.
Oh God,
you son of a bitch.
Have you had sex with guys in the room a lot?
No.
No worries.
Sounds that already sounds fucking gay.
All right now.
But that's not just guys in the room.
It's that guy there in her husband and wife safe.
I understand the safety of the broad,
you know what I mean?
I understand that.
What a sweetheart you are.
I understand the safety of the broad,
but I just,
the guy being in the room beating off would be the deal breaker.
Like you can watch where you gotta keep it pants.
Oh,
I don't even want it guy watch.
I don't give a fuck.
It's like,
you don't touch me.
You're over there doing,
she got to do it.
Why not?
Right.
And he was getting off to the fact that we were dropping loads in her mouth and
then he came in and fucked her right after it.
Oh,
good Lord.
In front of you.
He fucked her.
Yeah.
We just kind of pack.
I went to the bathroom,
cleaned up while he was funny.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Does he like,
I don't want to get graphic,
but did anybody come in her box?
No,
no,
no.
I,
I wore a hat with that always,
you know?
Yeah.
You have that situation.
I'm,
I'm strapping up.
I'm putting on my Hazmat.
So yeah,
for sure.
That's not the first time they've done that.
Right.
She might have some Ebola.
Oh No,
no.
She's a shoes.
They're meant hardcore smokers,
Florida.
No,
Toronto even crazier.
The first time I banged her was in front of him.
It was on some orgy in Vegas during the AVN,
so years ago.
Oh my God.
And it was like I'm banging her and then some other brides are getting fucked on
the bed and I'm just like,
this is great.
I'm like,
I'm fucking her watching her get drilled.
This is like porn,
like real life born.
People do go at it.
I went to a party once,
way,
way back in the day at the palms and uh,
we went up there to run into a friend and he was up there.
He goes,
come here.
You want to see something crazy?
I go,
yeah,
sure.
We go into this man is like,
somebody had rented this nutty sweet that had like,
it had a,
I'm a swimming pool,
like an outdoor area where they have it ahead.
A private swimming pool was like this insane sweet.
Who knows how much money does it cost?
We go out into this main room and there's a group of people around and they're
watching these chicks each other out and like this is like a movie,
like this is like a movie and a,
and he goes,
you always got to watch stuff like this because chicks will try to outsmart each
other.
Like watch,
like it'll accelerate.
So we're watching and as these two girls are eating each other out,
other girls started jumping in and they start pulling their tits out and stuff
at him and his girl's mouths and everybody has their own like little thing,
like how far they're willing to take it.
And some girls are just taking their pants off and bending their their ass and
other girls' faces and girls that they didn't even know him,
grabbed their ass and just started eating their pussy in front of everybody.
And I was like,
this is crazy.
How come I'm not at these,
this guy?
But this guy predicted it.
He predicted a whole off
and it really became,
it was a hoe down guy
tried to outsmart each other.
Who knows who's on what,
how many of were on Axis II?
Probably all of them.
Right.
But it was like,
this is like when you see a movie about an out of control,
drug fueled Hollywood type party,
this is what you say.
And this was in Vegas.
And people just walking around them go into where the drinks are going back and
forth,
you know,
it was,
it was ridiculous.
It was totally ridiculous.
See,
I like things like that.
I'm like,
I'm going to get people that take chances.
So there's some of,
and I'm a fan of the,
uh,
of the,
of the freestyle
Barrett.
Yeah.
There's some beauty in that,
right?
There's some beauty and just taking a wild fucking chance like that.
Why not?
What are you gonna live forever?
But is it okay to like live your whole life and birth to death and never do
that,
or is it better to do that and go,
I won't,
I don't want to do that again.
Yeah.
It's like,
oh,
I'd rather have,
I'd rather have a life of Oh,
wells rather than what if,
you know,
yeah.
Or a life of,
I probably should have done that.
Fuck.
Well,
don't you think also
you have a very different life than most people.
You're a professional entertainer,
a standup comedian.
Extraordinary.
This
is the,
this is,
this is the reason I indulge in all this because I'm like,
I still view myself like a regular person.
So when these things happen,
I go,
can you fucking believe that shit?
Yeah.
Like in my head,
I'm still the guy that works in the mall,
you know what I mean?
Right,
right.
When these things are happening,
I want to call my friends back home.
Like,
Yo,
these fucking chicks are eating each other out at this party.
You know what I mean?
My friends were like,
where are you at the mall?
You know?
Do you have a hard time like accepting the fact that you're look ridiculously
famous?
Uh,
I certain circles you ridiculous.
You're famous.
Yeah.
And,
and when I'm around a regular people,
I'm ridiculously famous,
but when I'm around famous people,
I'm ridiculously normal.
That's true.
Right.
You know,
like ridiculously famous.
You can make anything happen.
Let's Tom Cruise.
Kanye West.
Yeah.
No,
your height.
Yeah.
When Siri knows your height,
that's where that's when you've made it.
But does it the height of me.
Can you,
when you're doing these like 18,000 seat arenas,
is it freak you out when you get out there and you stand on that stage or
they're all there to see you and they go nuts.
I,
I still dig it.
You know,
I still kind of,
I,
I'm involved with it the same way.
The audiences like,
Hey,
can you believe this shit?
That's funny.
You know,
it's,
it's not,
uh,
it's not a bow to me.
You knew you should've been here.
Even I walk out like,
fuck,
are you doing here?
That's why you're not Kanye West.
That's exactly why we're Jesus.
I wrote there
Yeezus what diseases that him,
what does Kanye,
Kanye.
Jesus.
Oh boy,
that's rough.
That is rough.
You know,
some people have a god complex.
Do you think that's what it is?
You have to at some point a view yourself like that in order to call yourself.
He says it's just,
you're fucking hilarious name.
You know,
if this was the Middle East,
he be Jala.
Um,
that's right.
Or [inaudible].
Hammad y'all wait,
how do you spell Yahweh?
Yahweh.
Yahweh is God,
is it?
Yeah.
It's one of the names for God.
Why a,
why a w e or something like that.
Y'All way I got w e y maybe.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
there's a bunch of different names for God to John Jehovah.
Yeah.
Depending on the time,
the place,
I mean,
you know,
in a,
in all fairness,
I think Kanye calling small fuses.
Jay Z was calling himself Jay Jay Hove Jehovah.
Yeah,
that's true for that.
So,
but it seemed cute.
Old dirty bastard was calling himself God.
Was he a big baby?
Jesus remember all Dads,
right?
He called himself big baby Jesus.
He's dead now.
Yeah.
Much respect.
Rest in peace.
Okay.
Old dirty bastard was a perfect example of a guy that was just fucking as out
there as you can get for the level of fame and levels.
Song Rawhide that he did.
I have it on my phone.
If it was his,
his big hit.
He had like one zoo.
No,
he had another one like a sex one.
Fuck,
give me baby.
I got your money.
Yes.
Got Your mind.
Yeah.
Better give me that money.
Hey,
can I play rawhide or do you guys going to clear that shit?
Money.
Most likely we have to clear it,
but I bet if you play it off your phone,
they won't pick up.
Okay.
Bastard.
I didn't know you were,
but in this song he's just fucking,
he just starts rambling.
You're like,
what?
You could tell he was locked up when he did this.
It's like listening to no quarter by led Zeppelin.
They were high shit when they wrote.
This is awesome fantasy with Mariah Carey.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
Whoa,
whoa.
On a scale of one to 10 how close do you think you run?
Mariah Carey's?
I'm thinking she's pretty up there.
That's got you.
Gotta.
You gotta figure you've been detached from reality for at least 20 years at
least.
Right?
At least 20 the crazy superstardom stadium rock.
Yeah.
Well,
you could tell when she did that Christmas thing and her voice was all fucked
up.
Remember recently wasn't that,
isn't she going through a divorce though?
Yeah.
I mean you've got to give somebody a little,
well,
space can't be performed,
you know,
I mean,
I think if you're going,
especially for a woman when you're going through something like that and you now
your music is depending on your emotions.
Fuck,
you should probably sit back and,
and bow out for a minute.
Yeah.
But maybe she can't do that.
You know,
maybe they have obligations.
I would imagine someone like Mariah Carey's probably booked every day,
all day.
He's got shit to bring that paper hands Sutton.
I think her papers pretty fine.
Paper flowing though,
kid,
that mother fucker's got enough money to,
doesn't mean whatever.
I think he gets paid.
I think,
uh,
if you have to rich people and one of them is richer,
the rich Arab probably has to pay.
And how many Jay Z and Beyonce divvy up.
That's it.
It's pretty gcal match.
Now,
is that equal?
Pretty close knit canyons?
Uh,
their opinion,
that's just a porn name.
That's the Spanish version with the little thing over the end.
He actually is writing like,
there's all these rumors that he's writing this whole album.
Just bashing Mariah Carey through the whole entire album,
but amusing albums next album.
I don't think he needs that either.
Hmm.
Yeah.
He's never had a hit record.
So whenever we have to do to keep him from doing stand up and I say keep them
from making music too.
I think.
I'm just kidding.
Nick.
I don't even know you.
I'm sure you're a good dude.
It was just an easy,
he's a nice enough kid.
Never had a Mac.
They never even heard your stand up.
But I know we had Jay a big Jay Oakerson was joking around about it.
Well,
it's,
I mean,
I'm,
I,
I dare say I'm a friend of Nick's,
but how dare you let me joke about him.
Like,
but wait,
but I will,
uh,
I will coastline that his standup is not very solid without just sinks.
It.
We met up at the airport that we're in time.
Remember it right before it was like seven years ago.
Eight years ago at Burbank.
Oh yeah.
Now back in the day,
it's a nice enough kid,
I'm sure.
But when a guy,
uh,
you know,
gets divorced from Carey,
I think there's going to be some repercussions and he's much younger than her as
well.
Is He?
Oh yeah.
How old is she?
She's gotta be in her forties right.
And she easily,
what'd you hit it?
Fuck yeah.
Now?
Yeah.
Why not?
Who will just the story.
Yeah,
I fucked Mariah Carey.
The story.
Would that be 45 she's 45 and Nick's one 33 four.
Would you say have her sing happy birthday while you're banging on?
I would have her sing whenever she wanted and I'd make her sing emotion.
Make you come quicker.
Hit that high note,
hit that high note.
Ah,
the clamp.
Those celebrity romance type things,
they hardly ever work out.
Right.
We're too like superstar famous people don't know.
The problem is she was more famous than he was.
That's the problem.
And she was there around a lot longer than he was.
So she has legendary status and he has,
you know,
newbie status,
so to speak.
It's not as good.
You can't,
uh,
you can't,
you can't bank on that.
Is that what it is?
That's where it went wrong.
I think so.
I mean,
it's two different levels of fame.
That's the problem.
Yeah.
I fuck in my level of fame and everything.
It's possible.
I took an extra,
you know what I mean?
And that's a good move.
Yeah.
And you know,
you can't,
you can't fuck the leading lady unless we were the leading man.
But even if you deal,
you can't go backwards.
Yeah,
you can.
But he's always done.
He fucked Kim Kardashian.
He was Christina Milian.
He's been through a lot of really good chicks.
How dare nick cannon.
I'm going if that bothers,
I think that's what the,
what was the catalyst for them breaking up was he started naming off names.
Really?
Yeah.
But the chicks,
these bank.
Yeah.
And then Mariah Mariah's like enough.
Like what are you doing?
You're fucking married demeanor.
You're talking about other chicks at your banging teddy,
your bang.
How do we know that it's us talking shit.
We're just talking shit about some people we don't even know.
That's what Jamie does is time off.
I wonder if Jesus stays up at night thinking about the guys that Kim Kardashians
Bang when you were like a really like egotistical dude.
It's probably very difficult to deal with the fact that a lot of the guys hit
that.
Yeah.
And there's a video proof.
That's the worst part.
And she had a show where she was with her other husband,
you know?
I mean she was on her show with that other dude,
the basketball player dude man.
That's right.
Yeah,
she's a,
you know,
I don't know what to say,
but he gonna say,
you know,
what were you thinking about saying I don't,
we're in that fucking weird time where people are famous for no talent and not
that many though,
which is weird.
It's like for every one that gets through the net,
like Kim Kardashian,
like how many of them are famous for just a few moments and then it fades away.
They never figured out how to ride.
I know,
but the media is so fucking dumb.
They glom all over these people for no,
they really get on their nuts and they just let the talented people,
you know,
just stay in the line.
Wait your turn.
We're working on this right now cause it's about to expire.
Yeah,
but you know why?
Because will follow it
even though you're like,
even though they're annoyed,
there's something about those reality shows that people will tune in.
In advertisers,
all they do is a numbers game.
They know that if you get,
you know,
x amount of people are watching some show,
you play a commercial,
it's going to be seen by x amount of people that are in the demographic you're
looking for.
If that's the case,
they're willing to do it and people,
for whatever reason,
they don't like them.
You see someone on TV that has a real person live in a real life saying a bunch
of stupid shit and you get drawn into it.
You want to find out where they're going.
You want to find out what they're doing.
And they were really smart and what they did because what they did is they
involve their whole family.
Oh yeah.
To make it seem wholesome.
Well,
I don't even know if it's that,
but it gives you a lot of different people to tune into where's one Hilton was
only about her.
She couldn't sustain that.
Right.
But I think when you,
when you involve the whole family,
it shows,
uh,
a wholesomeness that America likes and it takes your mind off the fact that her
whole,
or some of her whole was the reason that we're here in the first place.
The whole,
I get it.
The whole sun and some hole.
You're welcome guys.
I'll be back next week.
Oh,
that's him watching it on a man that's fucking Washington,
Montana.
What's most shocking about that video is how much different she looked.
Yeah.
How much shit is,
shit isn't as big.
I rewatched it recently just because I wanted to know if her bub was,
I don't remember [inaudible] being that big.
It's half the size it used to be.
Yeah,
it's way bigger than it used to be.
Yeah.
We,
we'd better bigger now,
but it looked great back then.
Her body looked tremendous when it was natural.
I mean,
it was a beautiful body.
I doing all that shit to it.
It's just like it's,
it wasn't even really important.
Yeah.
Are you texting her right now?
I'm texting my nanny.
She asked me if I'm coming to see my daughter.
Oh,
well that's a little personal.
Sorry Mike.
I want to tell the whole Internet that.
There you go.
Yeah,
that's a,
it's a crazy thing to be able to just get famous by being a person,
like not a Sanger,
not an actor.
That's just never been a time like that in history.
If you start thinking about it though,
you can go back and go,
well,
you think back to the 70s and you went,
wait a minute,
why was so and so famous?
Paul Lynde,
why was he famous?
Who's a comedian was,
he know,
but could you,
could you ever quote a Paul Lynde Joe?
No.
No,
but he was on the Hollywood squares.
Yeah.
But then,
I mean like how did he get there?
Do you know what I mean?
It was,
did some movies and stuff before Paul Lynn's IMD B,
find out how you spell his last name.
L.
Y.
N.
D.
I was a big Hollywood squares.
He was one of those gay guys where you weren't,
they never said he was gay,
but everybody was.
Even,
even as a kid,
I was like,
something's wrong with that guy.
Oh God.
Even Jack Benny I thought was gay.
You know what Jack Benny gangs,
I don't know,
just seem gay to me.
Uh,
with the hand on the face.
The crazy one was rock Hudson,
rock rock.
You know who I'm friends with his,
uh,
we're just Semans no friends,
no close second,
his name is escaping me now.
Hold it.
Look,
he's in an old actor.
A tough guy.
Guy.
Uh,
Charles Bronson.
He's dead cheese.
Charlton Heston does he dead too?
Robert Conrad.
Robert Con man.
Yeah.
Really?
Who was a oh and he is so funny because he tells me stuff from back in those
times.
That's really blows my mind.
Oh,
well,
like,
okay.
You kept it.
Can't talk about it on the show.
Kenya.
I don't know.
Can I?
I don't you tell me.
Did,
I mean everybody talked,
told me about his dad.
Does that count?
Well,
it depends who's just tell me like Amina,
who he used to fuck who went and who was,
uh,
who was fucking hell.
Yeah.
Can I see?
You know,
can't say yeah.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Like he,
you know,
he called me back Natalie Wood and stuff like that.
Like I was like,
well,
so one of our rock Hudson,
cause yeah,
I knew rock and everybody knew he was gay back then.
Whoa.
I was like,
really?
He goes,
yeah,
he would just go off and do what he had to do.
Just do what he had to do.
Like a werewolf,
like a coyote stealing a chicken in the night,
just go out there and just attack the village.
Right.
Yeah.
Said,
then the Hollywood's been very accustomed to the whole gay thing for a long
time.
Well,
it had to be,
I mean it all came from theater.
Theater is filled with gay people.
Yeah.
There's no getting around that.
You know,
if you're,
if you're a homophobe but can you were in the theater.
It can't be homophobic and be in the business.
Know.
It's like being a Muslim and working for a pork factory.
Yup.
You've got some problems.
The business.
All right.
This podcast is over.
Can I never let you only can we just took it down.
Shit street then my bag.
I can't,
can't stop thinking about black cock holding and stuff like that.
Why?
Why Black Cock?
Holden's more populated in regular calc holding I think.
Oh,
you know,
because of Warren.
Yeah.
So that is willing as well.
But that is what that guy did like by watching.
Yeah.
Bang.
His girl.
That's cook holding ground.
Yeah,
but aren't you supposed to taunt them if you're a cook holding?
I believe so.
You should be like you.
Worm.
Yeah.
Piece of shit.
Fucking your bitch.
Yeah.
See,
I never did any of that.
I never,
I was joking with you.
Does prime,
I was more like,
hey man,
I'm fucking keeping my eye on you.
Can,
you know,
did you look at him in the eyes when you came?
No.
Load it.
Oh yeah.
She move that peg.
Oh good Lord.
I bet in the south black cock holdings,
way more popular than any other part of it.
It's far more wrong over there.
Well,
I used to have that bit about the statistic,
about the disproportionate amount of black of interracial porn being sold in the
deep south and then saw white people buying that shit.
White racist,
most slightly getting angry.
There's a like some like really like statistically significant number of more
interracial porn.
It's sold in deep south.
It sounds about right.
That does sound about right.
And we'll be right back.
You do come back.
We're all fucking game,
but nobody's looking at each other.
How much I international,
uh,
touring are you doing these days?
Uh,
it starts again.
January bunny.
Yeah.
Were you going?
Uh,
South Africa,
India,
Sri Lanka,
Hong Kong,
Singapore,
Malaysia.
Damn Dude,
south England.
Do you like you and those international tourists?
No.
Do you do,
I'm like months at a time or did you do a month at a time?
Come back for two weeks.
Month out.
Wow.
Two weeks.
Month out.
How many guys you bring with you?
Um,
let's see.
South Africa and India.
I'm taking Greg grow Gal.
Do you know Greg?
I know Greg.
Hilarious.
He's a good dude.
And Australia and Asia.
I'm taking the,
and Edwards.
I haven't seen Greg wrote gallon forever.
He's so funny.
Dude.
Australian where,
uh,
Asia I'm taking the inadequate is that,
that is a march.
Ian Edwards is a funny motherfucker.
You know,
I've known Ian 20 years.
We used to do a England together back in [inaudible] 95 weeks.
That's when we first met when he had the long dreads.
Yeah,
I met him even before that.
I met him in the early nineties,
like [inaudible] 91 or something like that.
Working at the Boston Comedy Club.
That's in the village.
Everybody.
Yeah.
That's a good dude.
He's one of the funniest comics and he's fucking great.
He's so funny.
He's so underrated.
You don't want people talking about like the best comic in the country.
He doesn't get put on that list.
He's on my short list.
One of the top five funniest guys in the country.
Yeah,
he's really,
really,
really brilliant.
Yeah,
he's fucking,
he was killing it the other night at the store.
Mike.
God,
I had a tweet about it.
It was just,
it was just,
it was just smashing it.
He's got some new bits about Ferguson,
about the riots.
Oh,
it's hilarious.
When you do comedy in Hong Kong,
are you mostly doing it to like soldiers then?
I don't ever do that.
Don't never do those.
It's always was for the locals.
Whenever I see somebody like,
Hey,
I'm in Qatar performing and then they're like on these military vehicles,
like go,
you're not in Qatar performing.
You're not,
you're not doing shit.
You might as well be in America performing because you're not performing for the
local people.
That's not world touring.
Can they understand you?
I mean,
do you have to change your whole world speaks English ignoramus?
Well,
I mean like reference.
I would say that winning.
Nope.
No,
nope.
Buddy.
We live in a very,
um,
Americanized world.
Well,
especially now with the Internet,
everybody,
there isn't,
there is a,
I always say there's like a level of understanding for the whole world and it's
America and then anything above or below that is a,
is whatever you are from and then you just take it to the middle and everybody
meets their,
yeah.
Like sometimes when people go to other countries,
I see.
You have to adjust some of your references.
Yeah,
maybe a little bit,
but you know,
you can,
you can get away with most of them for the most part.
I mean,
if you're going to do like a,
it can't go to like,
uh,
Australia,
Australian,
but like you're killing me,
La Ira thinking I'm like,
the fuck are you talking about?
You're killing me,
Larry.
I remember that.
Every,
every town has one of those crazy electronics guys are crazy mattress Canada.
Toronto has a bad boy.
Electronics.
No Buddy.
Nobody beats our prices.
Did you ever hear Crazy Eddie?
Uh,
no.
We have crazy Joe's drapery in Toronto.
There was a guy named crazy Eddie,
and he had crazy Eddie's electronics.
His prices are insane.
There was honest ed in Toronto.
He wound up going to jail though.
He did something that was fucking crazy.
Yeah.
But he did something really like tax evasion or something.
It was crazy.
Eddie can expect normal behavior from a guy named crazy heavy.
But that's really who he was.
It's really who we want.
So you really,
it was crazy.
It's out there living it.
Fucking Eddie.
We had this guy named Reichard Ford in Columbus,
Ohio.
And he has like pick from yeah.
And hence the largest dealership in the United States supposedly.
And he,
his thing was like,
we're dealing,
you know,
that's his thing.
But he got pulled over supposedly,
he got pulled over.
I with a hooker and cocaine,
tons of cocaine.
And so he made a deal with the Columbus police,
uh,
keep the saw on the DL and I'm raid,
donate my Lamborghini to deep the dare program.
So he,
there's this brand new Lamborghini and the Columbus Police Department that has
dare written all over it.
And supposedly that was the deal he made with to keep it on the DL.
That doesn't make sense that you know about that.
I had family in the police department.
That seems like one of those fucking stories.
Yeah,
it does,
but if you look at the,
if you go to the police department,
it's really odd.
They have like this really expensive Lamborghini and then
no budget,
no cams and Riker gave it to him like he's a guy cooked up one night and set up
loving them.
Love you guys.
Keep it,
keep it.
Put the air on it.
My one Tyson tried to give away his Bentley,
so the carbs.
Yeah.
He crashed it and he tried to give it to the cop and the cop took it.
Then had to return it two days later.
I think they lost their job too.
I think they were like,
listen,
bitch can be taken fucking Bentley convertibles convertible to a very nice car.
Yeah.
For Mike Tyson.
Mike's a really sweet guy.
You know Mike don't yet.
He's a very sweet guy.
Surprisingly sweet.
When you meet them,
it's like,
wow,
he's a,
he's a really nice guy.
He's a fucking gentleman.
He's,
well,
he's just gone through.
Everybody wants,
you know,
you look back on like a video,
especially [inaudible]
Tyson is fucking trash.
Oh,
so this was a long time ago.
Eighties and I mean it just felt really odd when he was doing it right
because he gave the guy on the left with the suit.
Now the guy with the guitar,
with the car dealer because he was like,
we're dealing and so he's the one that got busted.
He's the one that got busted
and I think this was like the chief of police,
but he's got his foot on the car,
like an asshole particular foot off the car.
I think it's on the bumper.
It's a smash bumper.
Is that one of those smashed bumpers?
It's hard to tell.
It's so low resolution to smash them up.
Derby car,
by the way,
I should,
uh,
let you guys know.
We'll be,
we'll be going HD very soon.
Apparently we have all the equipment coming in and a,
we will be using a tri caster and everything will be HD.
So all you people complaining about getting Grainy Shit on your,
uh,
on your television when you go full screen with it.
There'll be very different starting next week.
But we have to figure out what to do as far as like storing the videos and
uploading the videos cause there'll be much larger files.
So we're going to have
to get some Chai and hard drives and shit here.
It's a good shit.
Yeah.
So I'm on one of your last,
uh,
h irregular.
You can come back and come back in a couple of weeks fellow anytime you want.
I mean,
buddy,
listen,
you know,
I love you.
I'm like,
you know,
it's funny.
I think the last time I was here I pissed off all your viewers with how did you
that Emory had mix master Mike on and everybody was mad at me for talking over
him.
Oh,
well that's just,
you got to realize if you're,
if you've got a podcast that have,
at that time,
it's probably a half a million people listening.
You're going to get complaints,
whether they're rational or not.
Tell Russell or shut the fuck up and let Mike Talk.
And I'm like,
I was only saying things for him because I know as a Dj he can't say certain
things politically.
So I would say it for him.
You know what I mean?
And all the Djs love me for that because they're like,
you can say it because you're a comedian.
We can't say it because we're in the same fucking business,
like criticisms of electronic music and stuff like that.
You're just talking,
man,
you're on the podcast to talk.
You're not on the podcast.
Just so Mike talks and I think,
you know,
the good thing is we're on the other side of that now.
So things are good as gone.
He's gone through.
It's past,
it's past the idea that you know like anyone can comment on,
you know like if you do a comedy show or if you do a podcast or even a movie,
I mean anyone can comment on that now.
So like I've had guests on that I loved and like what a great guy.
And then I go to my message board or I go to Twitter and like that goes a
fucking idiot.
Like what?
Like be like more than one like three,
four people will go look I was talking about of his ass.
I guess your bullshit detector doesn't work so good.
I'm like why?
It's like that guy was great.
Like I want to be on where you have Neil degrasse Tyson on again.
I just want to sit here and watch.
It was almost here a couple months ago.
I was fascinated by that time for some other stuff.
But the day he was doing it I was fucking out of town.
I was even thinking of maybe flying in just to do it with him and flying back to
where I was with my family.
But that would cause Aki,
man.
And you've got to avoid those if you want to stay in your wife's name is pretty
even keel.
So she's such a nice person.
If she has extra released when you eat one of her chickens,
she beat the shit out of my dog dog.
I never seen her so fucking angry.
She's coming to Vegas.
No,
not only that,
the dog didn't totally kill a chicken.
No
rough.
Yeah,
the truck is on chicken.
It was,
how dare you,
you break its neck.
It was badly,
badly injured.
Only had a small amount of time left.
It was imminent death.
Like I looked at the wound and I was like,
oh Christ,
this is not something you could like patch up with a bandaid and it's just,
it's a bucking 140 pound dog,
you know,
a bid into this little tiny chicken,
whatever it weighs.
Wow.
You're sent to more of a man than me.
Cause if I had that,
I wouldn't,
couldn't be like break its neck.
I'd be like put a trashcan over it and like go on a vacation for two weeks.
Hey,
maybe if this coyote is really smart,
they'll figure out there's a chicken into the trashcan.
Well,
I mean I certainly did.
Where'd you dispose of it then?
Buried it.
I certainly didn't want to do it.
You know,
I'd way rather the chicken live.
These ticks.
It's very weird because I eat chicken still.
It's a very,
it's a very strange relationship.
Like I eat chicken,
I go to Kentucky Fried Chicken or church's chicken or whatever the fuck I'll
have chicken.
But I have these chickens that are my pets too.
Like I really genuinely loved them.
They're sweet.
It's a weird thing.
And their eggs are delicious.
My,
yeah,
I gotta get you some,
at least some of these,
they're,
they're like,
they won't be the same right now because they're not free ranging cause until I
get rid of this coyotes,
I can't have him wander around the,
there was a coyote in front of my fence again today.
Like in the daytime?
Yes.
During the days when they were going in because that's when the chickens are
out.
He like,
that's when we'd let the chickens wander around.
But,
um,
they have this like dark orange yolk.
Yes.
It's so much darker and more vibrant than the Yolk you get from those
and call those third world eggs.
Cause when you go to other countries,
uh,
that's what the,
that's what eggs look like.
That's what they're supposed to look like.
Yeah.
They're not processed.
It's a whole fucking,
it's just the food that you,
you give them because when we give him chicken feed,
then there yolks become very light.
If like they stay inside their chicken house.
They have a big chicken house.
Like if they stay inside the big chicken house and just eat the feed,
then they're yolks get to like a yellowish color.
The yolks we recognize.
Yes.
Yeah,
like the yolks.
Are you getting a store?
There's a place though a near my house and I was like legit free range chicken
eggs that they serve in the restaurant and you get the age,
she's like,
whoa,
these are dark eggs.
Like,
I recognize that stuff now,
but it's like the difference we were talking before about wild pork and like
domestic pork,
like a lot of the food that we eat is like so nutrient vacant,
you know,
there's not like way less than you would get if it was like the real wild
version of that.
What's the deal with the brown shell and the white shell?
That's a good question.
Um,
I'm white shells bleached.
No,
no,
no.
Some chickens just lay white shells and some chickens lay green ones.
We have ones like green eggs.
They're close to the Irish chickens.
Not I'd make an egg on,
not the um,
eat the,
call them Easter.
Eggers like some of them are dark,
like a dark chocolate and some of them are like a light brown is what we get.
A bunch of different color eggs.
Yes.
Weird
Penis.
I hook you up with a thousand a day.
Right.
You know,
I'm a closer to you now to come on over the hill fella.
Yeah,
I'm right there.
Don't,
don't get eaten up by the waves.
He,
he's just bring the eggs here.
We a microwave.
And make sandwich.
Microwave you son of a bitch.
We got good fucking eggs.
You want a microwave up?
There's no,
you don't know from this.
Do you think microwaving is bad for the food?
Is it,
does it do anything to the food that's different than cooking?
It just takes the taste.
It tastes,
I think you're taking away if you're,
I think you're wasting perfectly good food.
Like if you're eating the right food,
the type of stuff,
your reading,
the eggs and the meat.
You don't want to nuke that.
You want to nuke the shit that's already got the chemicals and shit
in it.
You know?
Hopefully the radiation will kill those chemicals.
It's way better if you just instinct like if you want to reheat a sandwich,
like a roommate,
it's way better just to throw it on the skillet then it is to microwave it.
Yeah.
Well it takes out all the nutrients.
It kills the nutrients and the taste and everything and yeah,
let's snope that.
Let's see,
cause I,
I,
I've always wanted to know because I've always heard people say that microwave
and kills the nutrients,
but I've never actually seen like any,
any studies.
So Russell,
what do you think?
I think that the radiation has to do something negative to your food.
Yeah.
Isn't there a reason why I feel bad for you to put your face close to a
microwave?
Isn't that crazy?
Is it good for you?
Maybe the government doesn't want you doing that shit cause you live forever.
My microwave is down on really low so I can't put my face
[inaudible] Nah,
microwaves and nutrition.
Let's see what they say to,
to,
to science based medicine as a concept that is larger than the analysis of any
specific topic.
Blom blom blom blom blom blom blom blom um,
okay.
Let's just way too big.
Here we go.
Does microwave the CNN,
does microwaving food remove its nutritional value?
Let's say the rumor zapping food in the microwave.
Leaches out key nutrients.
The verdict if you do it right.
Cooking food in the microwave is one of the best ways to retain your foods.
Vitamins and minerals.
Huh?
There are dangerous to microwaving your food.
You could get scalded for one if you use the wrong kind of plastic hint.
It's one that doesn't say microwave safe.
Unhealthy chemicals could seep into your food CFCs,
but if you're concerned about getting the most attrition out of your eads,
microwaving is a safe bet.
In fact,
it's near the top of the list for nutritionally sound food preparation methods.
If you use your microwave with a small amount of water to essentially steam food
from the inside,
you'll retain more vitamins and minerals than almost any other cooking method.
Wow.
That seems like it's written by Ge.
It's written by Bob Barnett.
Bob Barnett from CNN up wave dot.
Yeah,
calm.
I don't know what that means.
CNN up wave.com was make your mind up,
bitch.
What's one of those subsidiaries?
The lesser known CNNS.
Yeah,
and this picture they have a guy cooking peas in a microwave with a little bit
of water.
Hmm.
That's interesting.
Does microwaving cause cancer?
What do you think?
I think everything causes cancer at this point.
It says,
of course you can mess microwaving up.
Dump your veggies and a bunch of water and overcooked them and you leach out
plenty of nutrition when you cook food in the microwave,
cover it tightly creating an efficient steam environment.
Steven over a stove top is just as good though.
And some cases it may even be better.
One small study found that steamed Broccoli retained more of its cancer fighting
Sofo.
Wow.
So for a faint sulforaphane,
sulfur then
microwave Broccoli.
Okay.
But in most cases using your microwave to cook food,
it's covered tightly into microwave safe container with a minimal amount of
liquid.
It's a nutritional when,
hey,
so not see that coming.
Yeah.
Because,
um,
my,
my wife has a friend whose mom is like super crazy.
Like with everything has to be organic.
Everything has to be this,
everything has to be that she won't use microwave cause it,
it kills the nutrients.
And I was like,
whoa.
I go,
how do you know this?
And she's like,
well,
it's common sense.
And I'm like,
okay,
all right.
But I never checked into it till just now.
And now I'm like,
listen,
bitch is a thing called Google.
You need to get acquainted with it.
Living in that fucking,
those ancient times,
people were just passing down tales from generation to generation.
I,
yeah,
my mom does that.
Well,
especially when they first came out with microwaves.
Fuck number one,
it had a twist knob on it.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
What was that?
That was my,
my voice
was on cue.
No,
weird.
It's totally unclear.
Yeah.
So microwaving good Brian,
don't repeat that anymore.
That also was probably passed down from like a colored person told my mom or
something.
Oh,
colored person.
Well,
you deal with a lot of racial comedy to talk to this motherfucker.
Mine's from a more educated perspective.
I know.
It is.
That's why I'm asking you to talk to him.
Back in the day when a person of color,
person of color probably told my grandmother that.
Isn't it funny that you,
you can say person of color that is the politically correct way to stop colored
colored person is negative colored people is negative.
People of color is positive,
right?
Like we're just cause I think you're encompassing,
uh,
more people.
When you say people of color as a colored person?
I always suggest one type of color.
Yeah.
But I mean if it was look like a colored person did have no negative connotation
whatsoever and it was just like white people colored people.
Well I guess that's the other problem like colored people becomes like if you
say people of color,
you could have like a whole large group like from Sumatra,
from Puerto Rico,
from you.
You've got people from all over the place.
But if you say white people and then,
and then colored people like people on on his mat automatically seeing black.
Yeah.
Well people of color.
Why is that?
Okay.
I think person and people a separate singular and multiple pieces.
That one is so people of color,
like encompassing this wide range of different people and what colored person,
you narrow it down to one person and then it's basically which person do you
picture?
Yeah,
I guess I had a friend say colored people once.
We were like 16 or 17 or something like that at a diner.
And my dad used to say colored,
his grandmother said it.
My Dad just said coloureds and negroes.
But there was a guy who was the waiter who was a black guy.
He goes,
what color were they?
It's like,
you know,
like some ignorant Boston kids,
like arc in South Africa to make the distinction.
Yeah.
What do they say?
How did he say it?
Their palate and the lips and collards and Cooley's.
Everybody's dead.
What's the Cooley Indians?
You're a cooling.
That's what they used to cut our negative.
A negative or derogatory term out there.
Cooley.
So India,
is that a very common thing for Africa,
for him to come over?
Well,
yeah.
Well it's South Africa was when they eating on,
we're taking slaves out.
They were replacing them with Indians.
It's Kinda like you're Benz breaks down to give you a Honda.
Really?
Yeah.
So we were there as an indentured laborers.
Oh.
So like you have a debt to work off basically.
And we were working in the sugar cane fields in Africa,
southern Africa.
So it was like the Dutch came to Africa first,
right?
It was that the colonists,
the big,
the big boars.
Yeah.
We didn't choose [inaudible] and they,
uh,
they were also in Sri Lanka.
Please.
How'd he say it?
Cooley's you learned in new racial slur
but it doesn't like it.
Yeah.
Unless you're South African,
it won't really mean much to you.
Right.
Does it work?
Indians?
Is that offensive?
Like if you were talking to an Indian and South Africa and he said,
what do you Cooley's up to?
Let's see.
I could say it and it would be fine.
They would laugh.
They probably,
the older ones would get a little upset.
Um,
but if a white person says that they're kind of like,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
What the fuck are you doing?
What do you,
what do you,
what do you have anyone?
Even who you call him Cooley right now?
Yeah.
Those Inter Inter race expressions that only certain people,
white people don't have any of those.
He seen South Africa colored makes a lot of sense because there's black,
white,
Indian and colored over there and the colored people are basically a mix of
black,
white and Indian.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
So they're like,
well,
they're colored.
These ones are black.
These ones,
they're Indian and those are white.
And those are the colored ones.
Oh,
so when they say colored,
they're their meaning of a mixed.
Yeah.
There's an actual race of people in South Africa called that are colored people.
Really?
Yeah.
That's fucking bizarre.
Months.
Yeah.
But they're very,
very good looking women.
Really,
really good looking with them.
Boom.
Get it mean systems.
I'm sure.
What is it like over there?
Sounds.
I love it,
dude.
It's a little aggressive,
isn't it?
No,
no,
I heard it's very dangerous.
That's what they say.
But I,
you know,
I mean,
it's not any more dangerous.
You get into trouble if you're going to get into trouble.
Right.
You know it very rarely do people get into trouble that aren't supposed to get
in trouble.
It's not more violent there.
Anything like that.
I mean,
it is a,
it's not,
it's like going to the hood here.
You're going to get in trouble.
If you could go to the hood.
Oh,
I see he's staying here.
Stay in your lane.
You'll be fine.
So as long as you hang around with the right crowd in the right areas,
if you go to those areas,
you should probably be with people from those areas.
You shouldn't just wander in like an asshole.
What's it like doing shows?
They're great.
I love it over there.
Did you ever talk to them about searching for sugar?
Man?
No.
I,
this is my first time back after,
after seeing the film,
so I'm,
I'm curious to see what they want to know.
[inaudible] shit ever.
That was pretty,
wasn't it?
That movie was amazing.
Did you ever see searching for sugar?
Man?
Hmm.
I recommend it high.
You know,
it's really funny.
I knew one of the songs went really?
Yeah.
That song Sugarman,
you'd heard it when you were in South Africa?
No,
I'd heard it in a hip hop song.
Oh,
a long time ago,
man.
That's right.
He did.
Oh my God,
that's right.
What happened was that from,
I think it was the one with the golden feral face.
Yeah,
it was one of those ones.
It was like one of the late nineties albums.
Wow.
What song was it?
Do you know the song,
uh,
your demand?
You're the man.
Is that,
is that what it was?
What album was it?
I am still Madec.
Stillmatic she hasn't won.
Oh,
okay.
So that wasn't even that early.
It was illmatic was way earlier than nomadic.
And then it was a,
it was written than I am.
I think it was written was the one that,
uh,
welcome to the new world on it.
You're,
you ever heard that one too?
It was written.
Had A,
if I ruled the world and it had a shootouts and had some dre produced stuff on
it,
he might be the best lyricist ever.
Right.
He's the lot of a rapper's favorite rapper.
That shit that he did when he made that whole rap in reverse,
the rewind ramp it was in,
it was from,
uh,
one of the more recent ones,
like two or three cds ago.
He,
I forget what the name of the,
uh,
the song was,
but it was,
is it called rewind?
So he's done a lot of cool shit.
Yeah,
it's writing.
It's so good.
It's just obviously such a smart dude cause a very intelligent human being.
Did you see the documentary on him again?
If there's a documentary on illmatic really time is illmatic and it's,
he just breaks down the whole album over 20 years and I came together and it's
pretty cool.
Like you know there's an a,
there's a shot on the back of the album with him in the Queensbridge projects
with all the,
all the guys from the neighborhood and it goes through that guy's dead,
that guy's in jail.
This you what I mean like it's pretty cool.
Breaks down all the songs and how they got together and it's pretty fucking
cool.
It's on,
it's on showtime now,
I think.
Have you heard that song?
I'm in love with the Coco.
Yeah,
it's terrible.
It's horrible.
But it's already gone already.
Thank God.
But the guy got arrested for everything eat.
He raps about,
he's like,
yeah,
I robbed somebody and got up and I sell cocaine and I do this instead.
The police came in and was like,
all right,
so if we get a few out and cocaine charges and they just arrested him,
you can erase Bobby Shmurda.
Just got arrested too.
Who's that?
Some fucking loser had the Schermer to dance.
Well we were just talking yesterday about some guy getting arrested for lyrics
in a rap song and they were trying to indict him on crimes like murder.
Which one was talking about that guy?
Bobby Shmurda.
And what's he getting indicted for?
Shmita spelled S.
Schmurder arrested.
Yeah,
Bobby.
She attempted murder wrapper.
Spent Christmas in jail after arrest.
He had that song about a week ago.
Rested in drug trafficking scheme.
Sting.
So it was all good about a week ago.
Yeah.
I don't think this is the same story of this.
I think there's a different story.
Um,
there was one of them,
the,
this guy was getting arrested for,
uh,
lyrics just for lyrics.
[inaudible] is that it?
Probably the same one.
Is that it?
Yeah,
cause he was,
he pretty much just wrapped about what he got charged
for,
uh,
drugs.
Uh,
conspiracies.
Did you hear about Dmx?
What about them?
Uh,
apparently there was like a fake story that he had a bunch of dead pit bulls and
that he got arrested for it.
It was like a hoarding dead dogs.
Yeah.
But it was one of those fucking goofy debt.
Fake stories that keep people keep doing.
Yeah.
How weird is that that we live in this time where people can do that?
They just just
barely come up.
No.
See this is a different story.
The wrapper,
a rapper's lyrics result in arrest and eventual conviction as a different
gentleman,
uh,
Twain.
Gadi.
Yeah.
Please had been unable to solve the 2007 murder of Christopher Horton and Brian
Dean in Newport News,
Virginia Horton and Dean 16 and 20 were gunned down while sitting on the porch
in a town of 180,000 residents,
which suffered 28 murders that year.
Wow.
That's a lot of fucking murders or hunting.
80,000,
28 murders.
She 180,000 people.
Four years later,
detective can,
upon a video of a local rapper,
he had uh,
been tipped off,
blah,
blah.
That a song right out referred to the murders,
especially one verse which ran,
everybody saw when I fucking choked him,
but nobody saw when I fucking smoked him,
roped him,
sharpened up the shank and then poked him.
Three 57 Smith and Wesson.
Big scope.
Tim roped him.
Hmm.
Shmurda in October they got the other guy said,
my music is straight facts and he got a 69 count indictment that included
murder,
attempted murder,
dealing drugs,
weapons,
possessions,
that,
a list of other crimes in connection with a little long term investigation.
Whoa.
Because his lyrics,
his straight fast state facts.
Yeah.
He probably shouldn't have said that.
There's another one.
Could this rapper's lyrics wind him up in jail for life?
This is a recent one.
On November 17th this was a different guy,
a tiny do born Brandon Dunkin is facing attempted murder charges along with
other 14 other gang members.
The rapper himself hasn't been late to any shootings.
There are nine since April of last year that are being looked at.
If he doesn't have,
he doesn't have it.
He doesn't even have a criminal record,
but he could murder life.
Now this other guy,
tiny boo.
Oh tiny do Brandon Dunkin.
See there's,
I guess there's a bunch of these now doesn't have a criminal record but he could
be doing life behind bars based on a little used 14 year old law.
This is the story I was talking about.
The law as reported by ABC allows for the prosecution of gang members if they
benefit from crimes committed by other gang members.
So he is apparently down with his gang and because he's down with this gang
while they're doing crimes,
uh,
his affiliation being friends with them is enough.
Okay.
Instagram never had that problem with third base.
Remember those guys?
Yeah.
Know pop goes the weasel,
the weasel goes pop,
pop,
pop goes the weasel.
The weasel
for the prime minister.
Yeah.
They were very,
very angry at vanilla ice.
Yeah.
Remember that?
It's sorta like,
you know,
they mocked vanilla ice on the way to start him.
Huh?
White rappers is a tough fucking business.
M and m's been the only one that really successful successfully got through the
entire thing.
Unscaved like he's like super respected still as a rapper in 2014.
Who else?
Name another white guy.
Another white rapper.
Ready?
Go.
Okay.
Milk bone.
See Chris,
like I said,
search and he's not anymore.
Is it different things?
There's a deal.
He's a different thing.
First of all,
he's doing rap only for white kids.
You know,
it's a different,
it's a different kind of music,
right?
Like m and M is like respected in the hip hop world.
Like across the board.
Right.
State your name and other one.
It cross color barriers.
Yeah.
I mean just was so good.
He was undeniable.
What does that,
have you ever heard of it?
What is black widow baby?
Why you sing the song by Iggy Azalea?
How do you know that?
Uh,
because I'm dating a Mexican,
but she supposedly,
my Mexican is telling me about how I'm Mexican was like,
you're talking about my assistant was Iggy Azalea is like a completely made up
like a corporate person.
Like,
she doesn't even know how to rap.
And,
uh,
it's just like she was,
I guess she's been in a lot of interviews lately where they've tried to tricker
and doing like a,
you know,
a freestyle freestyle rap and she freaks out cause you can't rap.
And,
uh,
it's just an interesting story if you,
if you,
if,
if I wish I knew the whole thing and bettering,
so she's like a one woman boy band.
Yeah.
If manufactured from Australia and there was this other girl named Iggy Azalea
banks is not as easy just to Zillia banks.
Zulia banks who she's actually nick cannon's ex girlfriend too.
Yeah.
And she's actually got a little bit of talent,
but this ag girl is stealing all her uh,
shiny shiny swagger.
Yeah.
Swagger Jack or she's dating swaggy p.
Oh,
she is?
Yeah.
She's with which one?
Nick Griffin.
At anything
which,
which diggy diggy diggy is Iggy Azalea is dating the guy that plays for the
Lakers.
And who's the other one that's Azealia banks.
Azealia banks is the legit one.
Yeah.
She's like a singer though.
And Iggy Azalea is dating someone named swaggy.
Well,
he's that nick player and nick,
I mean a Laker player.
His name is nick something or another.
He lives on my old street like three houses down from me and he's a swaggy p is
his num deplore yeah.
Which is dumb because his name doesn't have a fucking pee in it.
Well for his penis clearly.
And then as he threatened like snoop Dogg like made fun of Ag and then uh,
he was like,
Yo,
snoop better watch it and watch it.
He's going to beat up snoop.
And Snoop was like,
I'm sorry,
are you saying he's going to beat up a cultural icon because he made fun of him,
but then apparently snoop apologized.
Well yeah,
but then like what do they want over there?
Texting people again.
I'm looking at a,
I just posted the picture of you.
Yeah,
just looking at the comments.
I'm checking them out right now.
Like staring into Satan's asshole looking for advice and a thing up.
It says,
oh my God,
that's the number 1.0 mg.
You want to see,
oh my God,
look at this Bryan.
This is a five megabyte hard drive being loaded onto a plane.
I'd seen that so far.
Yeah that's a five.
Pull it up,
put it on the online.
It's on my Twitter from December 29th from 1956 a five megabyte hard drive being
loaded into the back of a Pan Am plane.
What did Neil degrasse Tyson tweet the other day just cause we can't uh,
something about those uh,
those formations that we found ancient formations doesn't mean that aliens
visitors because we don't know what they are,
which ancient formations of these years and it was just talking as somebody
retweeted and I'm,
I'm obviously horribly butchering it and misquoting it but
no,
I'm just saying God looking at that.
Let me see that.
Look at that thing and it's insanity.
Five megabytes.
If your phone at five megabytes you'd be so angry.
Yeah.
Hi.
Why is your phone full?
I got a text,
somebody tried to send me a picture of my phone,
just keeps rebooting.
It's pretty great.
I was cleaning out my office the other day.
I was getting rid of my old Mac pro member that that huge hour,
cause I turned it on and see if it was even worth doing it.
And now it's completely useless now,
but it's so heavy and it's so like,
and now I'm replacing with this little Mac Imac that's like a thin piece of
paper and so much more powerful power.
Well that new Mac spinny thing,
the one,
the circular thing,
it looks like a thermos.
What's that called?
Mac Pro.
The Mac pro
called a tornado or a tunnel or something like that.
It's like something about the cooling.
Yeah,
like the,
the shape is conducive to more cooling.
I almost got one of those things,
but,
and then you could,
that thing gets expensive fast.
Yeah.
Like the one night priced out was almost $10,000.
Why don't you go back to making videos?
What's right?
I just got a new,
I just got a new the camera.
Yes.
Yeah.
Make videos.
Let's make something happen.
I am,
I just got a new four k camera and the new five k Imac.
I'm been in four k filming in four k.
It's amazing because like you can film this whole entire room,
but later if you want to like folk like say like you want to focus on just
Russell,
you could just zoom in on Russell and it's like amazing hds.
It doesn't,
it doesn't.
Yeah.
It doesn't look zoomed in.
So it's
Brian.
This best shit ever is,
is video editing.
Yeah.
It's the best stuff.
He does go red band.
That's why I hired him.
I hired him for video editing some along along the line it became a podcaster.
Yeah.
And I tried to start his own careers is video stuff was the shit I,
you know,
it's funny,
as I remember from the first time I came into your podcast and then to Brian
being just that guy and now he's a comic and he's this other shit and I'm like,
what the fuck happened here?
He's branching out.
I don't like this evolution.
He's moving up.
Come on man.
Show man,
I need to disciple.
Blew the fuck out Joe.
Joe,
you need to stifle people.
Show it gets almost 11 million downloads a month.
That's craziness.
That's it.
Yeah.
He became something that was out there slinging deck and I know making videos.
I don't know what this black video a baby,
but I don't want it in my head.
I know I don't want it in my head.
Brian [inaudible],
have you heard the uh,
I'm in love with the Coco.
Terrible.
I'm not,
I'm not hearing any of that.
Here's the good news.
That song lasts two weeks and it's gone.
You know,
you know what?
The fucking courses I got.
Baking Soda,
Baking Soda.
You know what's so funny?
It's cutting cocaine.
Eric B called me the Eric.
Yeah.
Eric B called me goes,
Russ,
you know what?
This fucking bullshit and I'm playing the radio.
This dumb motherfuckers singing.
I got baking soda,
Baking Soda.
What the fuck is wrong with these young motherfuckers?
Pop,
pop,
poker face.
Oh,
well the how did that become famous?
Because somebody poked her.
Faced.
How did that become famous?
Huh?
Remember when she got fat for a little bit was okay,
she got fat for a little bit and then boom,
snap back like a champ.
I'm fat right now.
We're going to try and say snap back,
but you can,
I help you in some way.
You're going to,
you know the ways to get thinner.
Why don't you hire a trainer?
You,
you got fucking shekels.
My friend know I need,
I need the right trainer who's got first aid can travel and B.
Yeah.
B can not be annoying while you're traveling nutritionist as well.
You could definitely get that.
I guarantee you there's a guy out there,
especially like there's a lot of young people or Gal,
but if it's cal might be a problem.
I'll end up fucking are trying to feed their own fucker.
Then she might be angry at all your sexism.
Unless she's Asian.
She won.
Expect what if she's Asian trainer girl,
she wasn't expecting fucked.
Really.
Don't even understand that comment.
You don't even question when he says something stupid.
Just take a deep breath.
Go like this.
Yup.
Oh Brian.
Well if there are any,
I know you have a lot of,
uh,
I,
I need somebody who can hold mitts and really train guarantee you.
We can find some people out there.
I had buddies just text me and like,
I can't take buddy
on the road because he trains real fighters for real fights.
Yeah.
You can't take him but someone,
somebody on that caliber who probably have to fight or do you want a lot?
You want to laugh?
I want them to,
I want them to really know what they're doing.
I mean,
they'll get paid.
I paid,
I'll pay,
I'll pay proper.
Somebody will contact you.
I guarantee you whoever you are out there that is thinking,
fuck,
I'll do that.
I don't go on the road with Russell Peters.
I love comedy.
Threaten me and man,
make sure I eat right.
Make sure you eat right.
That's hard.
Yeah.
They got a water for me because I'll fuck it up.
She's got to be caught that he parks right in front of the door in case you get
room service.
No,
I want to see.
I'm pretty good with that.
I will.
I will diligently do what you eat this.
All right,
but if you tell me to order it,
I'll fucking modify it.
Get an egg white omelet.
Can I get cheese in that place?
You know what I mean?
Like so I'll fuck it up.
He's got to give you the food.
Yeah.
Here,
eat this stupid.
You want it to be like all laid out.
Take,
take,
take these vitamins.
Not those vitamins.
What is your number one vice food and a lack of motivation to get up and do
anything.
Yeah.
Why?
Because you get too much money.
That's what it is.
Too much of a bullet.
No.
I want to let you know like I want to get up and run,
but then I'm like,
ah,
I'm tired.
I should probably take this time to enjoy the sleep,
you know?
And I do.
In those situations,
I get outside of myself and I say,
what would I tell myself?
Right.
If I was standing over me,
if I was like hired to be my own motivator and then I would ignore myself,
I would get up and be like,
get up you fat.
Fuck.
All right.
Just leave the room and then my fucking out of body.
So I'll leave the room and my fat self would just sit there and go,
oh,
thank God that motherfucker's gone.
Maybe you're just more comfortable than men.
Maybe it's that.
No,
you know what it is.
I definitely need to get my fat ass back in shape because am going to India and
the first thing they're going to say to me is we've gotten so fat.
That's the fat.
They have no hesitation.
You've gotten fat.
They'll say that to you right away.
Do that man.
You've gone fat.
They'll poke it.
Look,
you've gotten fat.
They'll show you,
look,
you've gone fat.
I try to eat,
you know,
because I get,
and then I get mad.
I want to hit motherfuckers because I'm like,
shut up.
I know I'm fat.
I don't need you to remind me.
Is that just the culture?
Yeah,
they,
it's just one of those things where it's not like offensive.
Just like,
oh,
what's with all the gang rape in India?
What's all that about?
Hey,
you know,
I don't know.
I'm not part of that gang.
But I mean it happens so often.
Gang rapes and murders like on buses and shit and trains.
We had to,
I don't know.
I don't know those parts of India where it's been happening,
but uh,
it's not,
it's not good,
but that's a gang dance a lot out there.
Right.
There's a lot of dancing going on in India.
No.
Took a breath.
I don't even know what,
ask an Asian trainer.
Maybe she'll tell Ya.
I think for real that we could find you someone that could put you in good
shape,
but you have to figure out a way to do that shit on your own man.
You up.
Well,
no.
Once I get into the routine and I see what it is and you're good.
Yeah.
Then I'll be like,
all right,
I got this for me.
If I don't maximize my time,
I can't sleep.
Right.
That's me.
I guess I,
if I,
if I'm like almost,
I was a fat fuck today and a bunch of stupid shit.
I didn't work out all,
I'm such a pussy.
I'll be like,
my head will bow if I,
I,
if I feel like if I don't respect myself,
like you lazy bitch,
you were supposed to do this.
You were supposed to do that.
You were supposed to write,
you were supposed to get this done.
You're supposed to do a podcast,
whatever it is I'm supposed to do.
If I somehow or another blow it off,
I can't sleep.
So I've realized that about me,
so I just do it.
I just do it.
Even if I don't want to do what I do it,
and then I feel good that I did it.
Yeah.
I,
you know,
I feel good when I do it.
Yeah.
I don't do what I don't feel anything when you,
do you know what I mean?
I think if I start doing it like in my head,
I'm like,
I know I should start.
I definitely had to have started this two weeks ago.
Do you,
did you ever your
except of resistance,
you know,
the concept of like a,
that resistance is something we battle all the time.
Resistance keeps us from getting worked on.
Resistance keeps us from accomplishing goals.
Absolutely.
That is like keeps,
it's like this thing that you like you have to overcome.
And there's this book called the war of art.
If you read it,
no heard of it.
Now,
uh,
the guy's name is Steven Pressfield and it's,
he's got a really interesting story.
He's an author and he was kind of a loser until he was like 40 and then by the
time he was 40,
he realized like,
Oh,
I'm just like not working enough.
I'm not doing what I need to do.
And that's why I'm unhappy.
It's one of the reasons why it's just not coming together.
And he realized that this is this thing that he was battling and he calls it
resistance and he's sort of like,
he outlines it in this really like easy to follow way that you can remember in
your mind and it actually can aid you in getting things done.
I used to keep him around the studio.
Remember Brian?
I used to hand them out to people.
I had a stack of them,
probably get a stack of them,
hand them in here.
It's one of the most valuable books for any like creative type or writer or or
perform or even of,
yeah,
I do.
I definitely need to change something in order to get out of this sort of,
in order to change things,
you've got to change something to change things.
It's obviously,
well,
if you're willing to hire someone to come on the road with you and then meet you
at your house when you're at home and,
and train you and you can definitely do that.
Kevin James loss like fucking 70 something pounds.
He hired this nutritionist to cook for him every day.
She had all these meals prepared,
like he went completely v there we got,
we've got a copy of it.
The more of ours Boone,
Jamie's a Ninja and I got wet goddess.
Does that one have a signature in it?
You'd better not give them the signature.
One.
Unsigned not signed to me and says to Joseph,
hey,
wait a minute.
I know it's up to look.
I show people that come and go,
what could she,
I met her,
her Sean right here.
It's a weird thing.
People in signatures.
Right.
But uh,
that book is excellent,
man.
It's really,
really excellent.
The guys are really good guy.
Had him on the podcast and he's just like a sweet guy to talk to.
Like you,
you'll,
you enjoy his company.
Yeah.
It's a great book too.
I'm going to take that.
You're not gonna to read it,
right?
I am going to to the odds will the odds you actually want it reading it.
The odds are low.
20%.
I'd say less.
I'd say 10
but the intention will be there.
My Dad used to say the road to hell is paved with good intention.
It's true.
What are the odds
of you actually hiring?
Well,
if somebody steps up,
I'm in.
Yeah.
Just have somebody open for you that does fitness.
No,
you don't do what?
They're not good.
Then they're going to suck.
Yeah.
They eat dick on stage.
They're going to be fitness.
Dig in their mouth and they're going to be asking you for advice.
You going to be paying them for them to ask you how to be a comedian.
Yeah.
And you're like,
oh great.
Now I'm training you.
I got this joke,
I've been thinking about going on stage.
I got this joke on to run a bar,
sit down,
I go to notes are run by money.
Imagine that.
Oh,
it's terrible.
I've had it.
You have you taken guys in the row with you that were mistakes?
Yeah,
I have.
I have indeed.
You know,
you regret that all the time.
What was it a mistake?
Because they bombed or because they weren't annoying.
Uh,
both because they weren't addressed that they bombed.
They thought they killed and you're like,
I can't have your dishonesty around me.
Yeah.
That's not healthy.
That becomes a real issue.
That that's,
that's where you find out where your,
uh,
your desire exceeds your talent and your ego dictates your movements.
That's good way of putting it.
You know,
the shielding yourself from reality.
It's like that,
that painful pill is like one of the most valuable pills.
Like when you don't have a good set and you can listen to it and go over it and
go,
oh,
like it will motivate you and you will.
And in seeing the things you do bad,
like a lot of people don't like it because they think,
oh,
this is going to remind me of my flaws and that's gonna make me see Jordan.
If you need that,
you need to look at that.
And then you need to look at when you were really great and go,
what was I doing different there?
And then get back in that mental space if he can.
You know what I did recently that helped me a lot.
You should do this.
It's really fun.
Do Ari Shaffir so skeptic tank,
Oh,
I've done that before.
I liked doing that.
It's great.
But he'll,
he does special episodes.
He's done like four or five of them or he goes over your special with you.
Oh really?
And he plays it and it asks you about the bets and,
and says what he really liked about this.
And did you purposely do it this way?
Like what?
That's kind of cool.
We,
yeah,
we did a five hour one for shiny happy Jihad.
Yeah.
We've just got baked and started rambling.
But,
uh,
after it was over,
I was like,
wow,
I learned a lot in that.
Like I learned like zoo,
it was all comedy that I hadn't listened to in like seven years.
Yeah,
it was.
It was all,
you know,
I've had people quote old bits to me,
go,
that's really funny.
Where'd you hear that?
And they go,
that's yours.
That's good.
I can't believe I wrote that.
I know there's some people are more of a fan of you than you are.
Yeah.
Because you know,
we're,
we're so used to just being shit on that were like,
ah,
I can't be worth much.
Well it's that,
and it's also,
you're in constantly in the cycle of creating new stuff.
Like somebody asked me a bit that was on my last special that I just did an
August and I had to go,
oh fuck.
Oh yeah.
They like said this part.
I go,
oh yeah,
that part.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
Well that's it.
That's how it works.
Cause without that,
I've abandoned that.
Like an ex girlfriend.
Yeah,
I know.
Exactly.
Hey,
remember when you did this bit?
I don't,
but if you tell me I'll,
it'll jog my memory.
Well,
I was laughing
at some of my bits from shiny happy jihad,
like I had never heard them before.
And then I re re remembered like after it I go,
oh yeah,
that's how that goes.
Oh,
that's funny.
Like I was enjoying it as a fan.
Spectator.
Yeah.
And also like criticizing it.
Like you can see where there's some dead air or where there some like,
uh,
maybe like too verbose.
Maybe it could have less words or maybe more pause.
He's always like,
oh,
he's little.
We have to all the,
all the things we all notice and nobody else will.
Yeah.
But those things,
man,
going over,
stuff like that.
It's like,
it's really good for it.
Like I know for fighters it's one of the best things you could ever do is watch
yourself spar.
Like watching yourself spar or watching yourself fight.
It's very important because you have a very distorted perception of what you
look like when you're moving around because you're only seeing it out of your
eyes even if you're looking at yourself in them.
That's why shadow boxing is important,
right?
Yep.
You got to see what your punches look like when they're coming out,
but to watch yourself actually compete or at least spar massively,
massively important.
We sit to film sparring sessions when I was a kid and I remember like watching
them like would make you so much better.
You're like,
oh,
I could get hit there.
Oh look,
what am I doing there?
Why is my hand down?
Yeah.
You don't even think about it while you're in the middle of doing it.
Hey,
in your head you're like,
fuck,
I'm killing this shit right now.
And you're like,
watch it go this way.
Sloppier than I thought it looked in my head.
I had painted this beautiful fucking picture.
You did a lot of boxing,
right?
Yeah.
When do you think that like that sort of like having that,
that really difficult thing to do?
Like what boxing is like really difficult to get good at.
Really difficult to like even show up at the gym every day at that like helped
prepare you in life like that does like a mom,
like if you look at the average person's like range of difficult things they
choose to do as a recreation,
not like go to war or something like that,
but choose to do as a recreation.
Boxing is one of the more difficult ones.
But I,
I,
I did it out of necessity.
Really?
Yeah.
I needed to,
I was just a small kid and I,
and I would get beat up a lot and I was not,
I was very passive and a,
when I learned how to,
it wasn't because I figured if,
you know,
if someone's gonna beat me up,
it's better.
I don't fight back.
So the beating ends quicker and I'd go on with my life.
That's a very Indian way of looking at things.
And then when my dad made me go and train,
cause my dad used to box in India and then some guys that I grew up with were
boxers,
then two and then I was like,
they went go train with willy.
And I went and trained and I was like,
Oh I,
this is okay.
I get it all right.
And then I started to like it and then I would almost encourage a fight
sometimes.
You know what I mean?
Like really?
So you think because you look at this,
that nothing is pop pop,
you know what I mean?
You're like,
Oh did you get a lot of street fights?
Um,
nothing crazy.
But yeah,
for quite a few I would say it's a great tension release reliever too,
right?
It is.
But I would also get very nervous in street fights because I,
at the same time,
I would see this person's confidence level and I'd be like,
wow,
they must be like a black belt in everything.
You know what I mean?
And then,
then you see them throw a punch and oh it's fucking
idiot.
Pop good night.
It is weird when you watch people street fight,
if you watch like a brawl outside of a club like [inaudible] guys so confident
that you would be willing to get out,
cause you don't know,
you have no idea what you're doing.
Winging these luck and windmill punches and that's why when you listen like boss
route and stories,
they're so hilarious.
Like you want to talk about [inaudible] shirt today?
Which one?
The pancreas.
Your pancreas.
Yeah,
I've got that.
Those roots of fight shirts are dope.
Is Fun.
The roots of fight,
sweat pants.
These
you going to full roots of fight wardrobe.
Jesse cats is rolling in his,
uh,
his PJ's right now.
Jesse,
Jesse reach out to Jesse.
Big Shout to Jesse.
He's,
he,
it's got a great,
it's great tee shirt company.
Yeah.
They have amazing stuff,
you know,
and gave me a really dope Jack Johnson one who is my favorite photo.
I've got that.
Is it the Galveston giant guy?
He's got his hands.
Do you know he was only like six to he,
but it's risks and risks like 13 inches or 14 inches or something like that was
a giant bag.
That was a fucking huge wrist on a human being.
Let me,
Sam,
I think I'm riding,
I'm thinking it's Jack Johnson.
The boxer.
I think it does five.
I mean,
I think it's a six.
A six.
I think he was six even,
wasn't he?
Yeah,
I think he's a little taller than that.
I think he was like kind of legitimately,
legitimately tall,
but they called him the Galveston giant six feet.
You're right.
Six feet and a half inch.
That was a giant pack then.
Yup.
Wow.
That's so crazy.
Risks.
What was his wrist?
I don't know.
I'm looking at Wikipedia.
Um,
that is crazy.
He was only six feet tall and they called them the Galveston giant and he was a
defensive master.
Oh he was such a good boxer for the time.
But here's also like such a knockout puncher.
Yeah.
He would hold guys up.
He would hit you see your knees buckled and jump in and hold you up so that he
could abuse you a little bit longer.
It's really interesting watching those old fights man.
Really fucking interesting.
Such a different style of a,
of fighting with those little gloves and long and the way they moved it was very
archaic.
Yeah.
So archaic like you compare him to like how may were there moves like
Mayweather,
like I think is one of like people don't like him because he talks so much shit
and because sometimes he doesn't knock guys out.
Just wins by decision.
But as far as like technique and skill,
technically boxers ever,
ever.
I,
you know,
I think a really any either really interesting fight or really boring fight
would've been him versus pronounced Whitaker.
Oh yeah.
Cornell was like the Mayweather of the his time as far as fighting style goes.
Yeah.
How's he doing these days?
He's a little fucked up I think.
I think it's training guys and he was like,
he was,
he had a drug problem for a minute.
I don't know if he's over that or not,
but it's so hard watching your,
your,
you know,
the heroes of your youth sporting year.
Just be debilitated as older men now.
You know,
you've seen it with football lot,
you're seeing it with everything,
but man,
with boxing it takes on a special special,
a form,
you know?
Yeah.
It's one of those things where you're like,
oh,
that could have been fucking,
that could be any guy.
I know we were talking about de la Hoya last night.
The day has is looking in his eyes always.
Who's about to relapse?
Like at any second,
he always has a nervous twitch in his eyes.
You know,
like somebody's going to find something out about him.
Just that look of what do you know
what you think of the photos that were out?
I mean in his macho world of not just a boxer,
world champion boxer,
but Mexican,
you know,
like,
and then to not be accepted by the hood guys.
Yup.
And you know,
it's not like he came from like fucking,
you know,
Woodland Hills.
He came from the hood too.
He's from east La.
Yeah.
But then to have that and then photos of him with fucking fishnet stockings on
high heels.
That never helps you hanging out with hot Russians.
Yeah.
That's a hot,
that pitch was,
she got an wore stockings.
Yeah.
See you can't do that.
I've,
I've put pantyhose on my dick before.
Did you know,
like she took him off in a wrapped around my deck and I was wondering why did
you do that?
They have a foot fetish.
Do.
Yeah.
I can do this already.
Oh,
you were talking about feet last night.
That's right.
Women's.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Is there a dude out there with a dude foot fetish?
That'd be fucking,
yeah.
There must be.
Why even ask?
There must be knee fetishes,
shoulder fetishes with others.
There's all kinds of,
you give an extremity,
there's a fetish for 7 billion people.
Right?
There's gotta be a elbow.
Yeah,
I did it.
A hot chick with thicker angles.
Frankel's shit.
Big Ass ankles built.
I'm not mad at them.
You know,
probably.
Pardon the inner tall hot neanderthal pussy.
A lot of those Europeans,
they've got neanderthal genes.
They do.
You know,
but all that,
they do that.
I can understand that.
Well,
that's where they would come from,
right?
Yeah.
I think,
well,
France,
right?
Wasn't that part of a France where they discovered the first neanderthal?
That's what they call it.
Neander tall and feel like sophisticated.
Yeah.
You don't say Thall neanderthal social,
say the Thames River.
Oh,
do you?
I don't even know how to say that.
Not The fames.
Oh really?
It's t.
English.
A tricky spot.
How did you get to be so famous in England?
It's all youtube shit.
Uh,
I used to be there all the time in the nineties.
Oh really?
Doing like the comedy clubs,
comedy store there.
La Junglers,
the glee club,
all that.
I fucking huge boom in the 90s.
And I was there for it.
And just,
you did 20 minutes spots.
It's all you would do really.
And you would,
you'd get paid in pounds and it was great money.
And you could do like fucking four shows a night and get paid on each one of
them because they have an agreement with the comedy store.
No,
they do not jack name.
They jacked the name.
The logo.
The logo is the same.
Yeah.
Whoa.
There's nothing you can do about it cause it's another country.
There was some sort of weird thing where like they got away with it.
That's hilarious.
Does the comedy store in Sydney too?
There's one in India as well.
Really?
There's a comedy store in India?
Yeah,
there's lot.
Again,
it's based
out of the one in London.
Oh son of a bitch is going International Jackman name and then go international
with it.
Motherfuckers now when they do comedy in England or in a,
in India rather or they do an English version for the most part.
Really?
Yeah,
so there's that many people that are English speaking and he figured there's a
1.3 billion people there if fucking 1% of the population speaks English.
You're good.
How much bigger is India than the United States?
Geographically or geographically?
I don't think it's much bigger.
It is.
It's a sub continent so that means there's like four times as many people in the
same spot.
Yeah,
like you go to a city like Bombay and there's probably 30 million people,
which is the population of California in a city.
How often do you go there and perform?
A once every two years.
I'm going back in June next month,
February.
I think I'll be there.
I'll be there on Valentine's Day.
Matter of fact,
how romantic I know I'm going to go to Bollywood and hang with the stars.
I will be in Bollywood,
Bollywood.
Like what does that,
it's just the name
for Bombay's.
Hollywood is all the things,
but is it the same sort of seen as like the Hollywood out here?
I mean,
you tries to be,
you know,
it's a little more,
it's,
it's every,
you know,
when somebody thinks something is some way and then that's how they portray it
as opposed to it actually being one way.
Right.
It's more that this is what we think you guys are doing.
All right.
Oh,
I see.
So it's like they're posing.
Yeah,
there's a lot of disingenuous,
um,
uh,
likes and stuff over there.
You know,
it's kind of like,
oh,
this is the hot thing,
this is what's good.
And you're like,
yeah,
but you don't really like it.
You don't really understand it.
You don't understand the origins of it.
Like,
you know,
it's whatever's hot is what's hot.
It's like von Dutch hats.
It's like a,
it's like,
it's like ed hardy had already,
I mean,
oh,
this is everybody's wearing this,
but nobody likes it.
Well,
why are you fucking wearing it?
Some people used to look at what ed hardy used to be was a classic American
style of tattooing.
Right.
Like that was,
that was the whole thing about it.
The sailor tattoos.
Yeah.
Those,
those Americana sorta like really kind of like shitty drawings.
Really know what it is.
They're kind of shitty.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well the,
you know,
the anchors and all that kind of stuff.
Tiger faces,
they don't really look like tigers.
But then somehow or another that became cool.
Like now that I've seen some really good versions of those tattoos,
but then it became a like a shirt company and everybody was wearing it for like
two years and then the Christian Hud did ga whenever the fuck that shit was too.
Yeah.
That's the guy who created at hardy,
right,
isn't it?
Yeah.
I had a Christian Azure,
this shirt and then affliction jumped on it.
Well,
they got really Scully.
Yeah.
And like,
like all like dad did destruction these to pay me.
I used to wear affliction shirts for the UFC where affliction like while was
doing the broadcasting and had like a little small affliction logo.
Yeah.
But that was when my friend Tom was Tom Atencio who uh,
he was like one of the owners and they kicked him out.
So I stopped wearing it.
Yeah.
They had like six or whatever you want turn dispute and the other guy.
Well now I wear tailored shoots.
Suits that Fox gets me or that the UFC gets,
but I have noticed it cleaned up a lot.
Yeah.
I'm beautiful.
Beautiful Man.
Those uh,
tailored shirts,
are they,
they're comfortable where like tailored pants because they fit you,
they're made for you.
Exactly.
They're not made for a guy around this size.
Yeah.
Most people can buy like regular clothes,
but I have to buy a troll clothes.
I have to be trolled troll like physique.
Yeah.
I mean you've got broad shoulders of thick neck and then a short torso.
It's really the legs,
the real issue.
I get strongly,
I carry all my weight and run my dick bag all around the trunk.
Yeah,
trunk and my Dick.
But I got skinny Indian legs.
I got skinny boxer legs.
They would notice boxers never have big legs.
Tyson that hugely.
Yeah,
he had big calves.
That's where the all the power punchers have big legs.
Yeah.
Manny Pacquiao,
giant calves.
That's also bad in boxing isn't,
you don't want to have to muscular of a cab because you can develop compartment
syndrome where you are because you're on the balls of your feet the whole time
your muscles tense up.
They could lock up on your debilitating,
it doesn't seem to bother Manny.
No,
I mean he's pretty flat footed but he bounces flat foot.
Do you know what I mean?
So well he moved so well as fucking hard.
They did a study on many pack yells skeleton and they,
they noticed that he has like are extraordinarily thick wrist and they were
equating that to a punching power and they were saying like what's one of the
ways he punches so unusually hard.
It has to do with the size of his bones and the size of his risk of the density
makes it a more solid as opposed to a pinpointed pool cue type of shot.
That's a weird thing about boxers.
Like there's like you look at their physique and you'd go,
well that guy looks like really strong.
It looks like you'd probably punch is pretty hard.
But no.
Sometimes guys are really well built and they can't punch hard.
Yeah.
And then there's other guys that have a lot,
it depends where the weight is.
Right.
And which Tyson was short and stocky.
So it was a,
it was a lot of explosive power in there.
Yeah.
But he looked like a guy that could punch hard.
And he had those legs.
That's where your power comes from in the first place.
Or,
but like Andy Lee pref example,
you know,
the Irish guy would just one,
what did he win?
What titles I'm middleweight title is,
yeah,
I believe so.
He's got a vicious right hook.
Just vicious.
But you look at him and he looks like a regular guy.
Like Gennady Golovkin perfect example.
He looks like nothing.
Well,
he's built kind of these,
it looks athletic,
but the way he punches just fucking murderers.
Yeah.
You know,
like Julian Jackson.
I remember Julian Jackson,
Virgin Islands.
Good Lord.
Could that Guy Punch hard rock and hit?
But he also had that he had an Adonis like body Donna's like,
but you can have a guide.
Like perfect example is um,
Toni Bradlee,
Timothy Bradley.
Bill like a fucking brick shit house.
Harley knocks anybody out.
Yup.
You know,
he's,
he swings hard too,
but just guys don't go.
It's weird.
Like some guys just have that crazy can casa.
I also think it's Keith Thurman has crazy,
Ooh,
yeah.
He doesn't look like he has any problem.
No.
He's a perfect example.
He looks like he's going to be all ready for the world.
All his hair.
He's wearing braids and shit,
but he,
he knocks out.
Dude's dead Knox and Deborah in his last fight where you went the distance.
How about a Donna Stevenson?
That motherfucker can punch.
So cause you just say yes,
he can.
Yeah,
he's an engineer.
He's undefeated American 32 and 32 knockouts,
but they're not moving them towards Klitschko.
What's that about?
No,
they don't need to.
They're going to,
he's fighting stover and for a title,
why would you fight?
Klitschko yeah,
but why not?
Why would you fight the guy?
You might as well get the title from Vern and then make a big money about
against Klitschko to bring the titles back to America and Blah,
blah,
blah.
And then you're gonna get knocked out by Klitschko.
Do you think so?
Yeah.
Chris has got way too much experience and,
and clutch goes,
uh,
a boxer fighter.
Like,
Hey,
it's what he did.
And then s and wilder is a guy who was like,
hey,
you're really strong.
You want to box.
You think so?
Yeah.
He's kind of fabricated almost to a certain degree,
but zoom like 32 and he is 3,232 knockouts and he's gotten a fabricator.
That sounds,
I mean,
look at his records.
look at the guys.
He's fine.
It's not like he's fine.
You know why that was a hard guy to fight,
you know?
Well,
he's got power and he's a big guy.
He's a big dude.
Isn't any light at least like six,
six or 600.
Right.
What does,
okay,
let's listen.
I've met him.
He's a big fucking guy.
Um,
what do you think he weighs?
Probably run to 22 to 25 maybe he's six foot seven.
Six.
Jesus Christ the way to 30.
That's a big fella.
Um,
so doesn't have it in his Wikipedia.
Doesn't that was,
wait,
let's ask Siri.
Yeah.
What is the weight of Deontay wilder
checking on that.
Here's what I found on the web for what is the way to dying?
Wilder.
Hmm.
Diane?
Uh,
no.
His middle name is lashawn.
How dairy pro debut and uh,
they want an Olympic bronze medal.
Okay.
So he has a little bit of an amateur record.
Yeah.
How dare you?
My Dad taught me bed,
my bed.
Wait,
I'll admit when I'm wrong.
Let's see.
215 pounds.
Yeah,
it was right.
He's to 15.
Yup.
Oh,
that'd be six foot seven 250.
He's very tall and lean.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
That's not a good way to fight Klitschko at well,
it's a good height to fight Klitschko App.
Yeah.
But then you know,
you don't if you don't have the,
uh,
okay.
I mean,
I mean weight's not everything,
but I mean,
you know,
if you're getting hit by a guy the same size as you,
a good big man will always beat a good little man.
Yeah.
And A and Klitschko it would theoretically be the bigger man cause he's at
around two 40 to 50.
Okay.
Yeah,
he's definitely bigger.
He's also just so smart.
The thing about clicks goes built.
He's not like,
you know,
uh,
a fabricated size man.
That's just the fucking way he is.
Yeah.
He's,
he's got stuck genetics.
You ever see that video where Deontay wilder,
he fought an Internet troll.
Yeah.
He wouldn't beat the shit.
It's so crazy that the guy showed up.
The Guy who went to the gym with him,
I think the guy thought it wasn't going to happen like that.
Really.
I think the guy was like,
what are you going to do?
Beat me up while the guy was talking all kinds of crazy shit and then agreed to
meet him and I think it was at the Hollywood gym,
that gym on mentoring mad as fuck.
He beat the shit out of that dude was so late and he was down.
He was punching him.
Yup.
Yeah,
that was,
I needed it.
Fuck yeah,
you did.
Yeah.
It's just weird that they,
uh,
that the guy actually put the gloves on,
you know,
I think he just thought as he's going to toy with me,
we didn't,
I mean he would make me make,
maybe,
maybe hurt me a little bit so he can teach me a lesson.
Here's an article on ESPN boxing.
How rude is this?
Is Deontay wilder another heavyweight hoax like Gerry Cooney before him knockout
artists could crumble if not truly tested.
Huh?
Deon taze got holes in his defense is what the problem is.
Does he?
Yeah.
They're trying to tighten that up.
Who does he train with?
A,
I know my boy Russ.
Amber was training with them for a little bit.
I don't know if he's still with rust,
you know,
rust.
He owns rival gear?
No,
no.
I've heard of rival gear though.
I think that's like a really significant part of a fighter's career is who's
teaching them.
It's so significant,
so gigantic.
I mean,
you can have all the athletic talent,
oral,
all the desire,
all the historical knowledge of boxing.
But if you're not have a god,
it's right in front of you.
That's catching little habits.
You see a,
you see it with Mike,
you know Mike Tyson when he changed from,
you know,
from Kevin Rooney to a Richard Gere Ketty and you know,
I'm fucking errands snowfall and shit.
Like it's all going downhill from here.
Well,
he was already just on a spiral by then.
Once custom motto died,
it was probably very difficult.
You should have just kept Kevin,
you know,
Kevin had cussed style down to a tee and Yup.
And Kevin pro boxer himself.
But then there was a lot of issues there.
You know,
I don't think anybody could live like Mike Tyson lived and make,
get it through unscathed and figure it out every step of the was no way.
He just going to get too crazy.
Yeah.
You can,
there's no,
no matter who you are.
I mean it's just the excess is so much.
Yeah,
well it's like you see,
I mean,
I've said that about Justin Bieber,
like people like just to be researching asshole,
like you don't think you would be if you in 19 $19 million in the bank and
nobody's telling you know,
nobody.
How could they even his dad's part of the entourage.
Shanice Dad's happy to be there.
Super happy.
Yeah.
And he's 19 at the end of the day,
he's fucking 19 year old boy.
What would you do at 19 you were,
I was an asshole with no money.
Exactly.
You know what I mean?
So it was a little boy.
He's a boy doing things that a boy would fucking be doing.
I was an idiot when I was 29 yeah.
10 years later I was retarded.
This fucking kids out there with $1 billion.
Got It plain for Christmas.
He got a plane for Christmas.
That was a lie.
Yeah.
He's just,
he just took a plane at that planes for sale though.
But he just took it and took photos and I said,
hey,
look what I got for Christmas.
How do you know it was on Tmz?
I would say that TMZ,
if I've encountered a bunch of hate and be like,
don't tell these people that I probably got high too is kind of freaking me out
that I told everybody we got to play in the solemn line.
Yeah.
And then Mayweather was like,
yeah,
look,
congrats Joe to joining the jet club or whatever.
You know,
how long before May,
whether after he retires becomes broke the way he does things.
That it could be sooner than you think or not.
Wasn't he like he was a situation before he signed with golden boy where it
didn't he oh,
a shit load of money.
Like he needs to pay,
you know,
a lot of these guys don't pay their taxes and then,
yeah.
But I mean he started making a lavish habits that cannot be maintained,
have any gamble gambles.
That's going to be a downfall.
Gambling can be her downfall,
uh,
going to strip clubs and dropping $1 million in there.
He does that well,
100,000 sometimes.
You know,
just fucking,
it's just good kid.
I'll just have fun,
but isn't that way you're supposed to,
you should do it once in a while,
but it's,
you know,
it seems like he does it all the time.
It doesn't even make like $100 million a fight or something crazy like he does
make a shit ton of money.
So if you made 100 bucks at a Gig,
go to strip clubs to drop one,
drop a dollar.
Oh,
you're like fuck it.
Throw it on that table.
I was going,
well,
fuck yeah.
Run around the room and then slam it.
Put that dollar down.
I made $100 to date.
Crumple it up.
Throw it here,
bitch.
That's what he's doing.
I mean,
isn't that crazy?
It makes $100 million,
I guess.
You know,
that's $1 million,
but you got to,
he's got a huge team around him.
Giant.
Everybody's got to get paid.
It's going to be interesting to watch how that plays out because he's 36 or 37
seven starting to slowly but surely reached that age where you're like,
okay,
how much longer can he's got to start weaning people off the teat?
Yeah.
I mean how many guys can do with Bernard Hopkins has done maybe only Bernard
Hopkins 49 years old,
but Bernardo never got the money that may,
whether it's true,
so still hasn't.
Right,
but he's still made millions.
I mean don't cry for Bernard Hopkins,
but he's 49 years old and he's still fighting guys like Cobra Love,
which is just incredible.
I hope he's retired by now,
right after that.
Like,
oh,
I don't think he's going to,
I think he's going to keep going.
I don't think that's,
I think the mistake he's going to make.
I don't know about that man.
I watched the Donna Stevens fight and the Donna Stevens knocked out that Russian
camp,
but I was like,
you know what man?
That guy kind of stood right in front of them.
You know,
he,
he probed him for a while with like the low jab and moving back and forth,
but at Donna's hits so goddamn hard.
If you've got any holes in your game,
Adonis is going to find him.
He's going to plug them up.
Yeah.
I think he could.
Outbox a Donna's take a time and then retiring.
I could see it.
I think he could be at a Donna Stephens,
I think,
isn't Sean Pascal fighting?
Somebody isn't,
I think he wants to fight it.
Donna Stevenson.
Well didn't because they're both much real him.
Haitian guys.
Hopkins beat him,
right?
Yeah.
We beat Hopkins.
Hopkins beat him.
He beat Hopkins.
John Pass.
He beat him in one fight.
I Dunno.
And then they had a rematch.
Let's find out.
Let's do Bernard Hopkins.
So they fought twice,
right?
Uh,
maybe Bernard.
I could text John Pascoe.
Can you,
you know,
I do Canadians,
we all know each other.
The,
you know,
GSP.
I do.
You do know you know him well.
No,
I know for Ra's better for us as a fucking great guy.
I love that dude.
Do you think that George is going to come back?
Um,
uh,
he needs to desire to come back.
He looked like he had lacked any kind of enthusiasm to be there anymore.
You're right.
Almost he beat John Pascale and how to draw was John.
So that was four years ago and the incredible,
he was fucking 45 back then.
Yeah.
And he's still swinging and does that,
that's,
you know,
that they say that he's probably older than he says he is too.
Because when he was in jail,
really?
Yeah.
They say he might be like in his fifties but that's crazy.
How does a guy like that and maintain?
He's never been in wars.
He never got beat up.
You know what I mean?
I understand that.
But I mean,
the physical reflex is involved in professional boxing are so,
it's so significant.
I think it's one of those things where he stays training.
He doesn't,
there's no,
there's no time where he has to get back in the gym,
you know?
Yeah.
I think if you continuously stay in the gym,
you'll be okay.
Like Mayweather.
Mayweather is never out of shape.
Mayweather.
Literally has to gain a couple of pounds to make weight.
Yeah,
I guess that's it,
man.
I mean it's the only thing,
it's the only thing that makes you walk around at wait all times.
I mean,
how hard is it to,
to maintain that,
but it's also lets your lifestyle,
you just abuse like your knuckles,
your joints,
you know,
everything just going to slowly but surely,
I guess.
But it's,
you're going to have to go that hard all the time.
Yeah.
I mean,
but when you fight a guy like Coldwell lab,
you have to,
I mean you're,
you're fighting 12 he also underestimated Kovalev.
Do you think so?
I think so.
I think he knew Koval I've had power,
but I think he thought he'd get out slick him.
Yeah.
Well that was what he was saying,
that it was going to be Kelly Pavlik too.
You know,
Kelly Pavlock was that really put them on the map again,
you know,
after the Jermaine Taylor,
that was a big venture and the public just fucking took a shit.
His career took a shit after that.
Well,
yeah.
The problem with the booze man.
Pavlock yeah.
Pavlik he had a sad case.
Youngstown,
Ohio.
How was that?
How far is that from me?
That's Tony Hinchcliffe his hometown to two hours.
Yeah.
Kelly Pavlik that was way back in 2008.
Isn't that crazy?
That was six fucking years ago.
There was a huge upset,
unanimous decision.
12 rounds.
I shouldn't say huge upset,
but it was a pretty big,
it was a pretty decent one.
Beat Antonio Tarver remember that?
Yeah.
I spend a lot of fucking guys,
man.
Tarvaris fighting at heavyweight now he's he back.
Oh yeah.
How does he look at heavyweight?
Oh,
he's good.
He's training hard.
I mean,
I'm friends with him as well and uh,
his,
he's,
how old is he?
Tarver is I'm,
it's my,
yeah,
he's 45.
He's 44 45 it was 46.
even that's old.
Yeah.
But again,
you know,
to be fighting.
He's calling out,
calling out Klitschko everyday.
Is He?
I think he's,
you know,
he's trying to get that paycheck before he can get out of there.
How good is he still?
He's still,
he's,
I mean he knocked out the last guy he fought and he did it two weeks ago.
Wow.
46 there's a difference though with heavyweights,
right?
That hey,
we seem to mature later.
Like George Foreman,
when the tile at 46 44
46 he knocked out Michael Morgan was a 44 oh one thing.
I would double check that.
Well,
you are a fucking boxing wizard.
Ordinarily I'd go shut up bitch.
And you know more about boxing than I do.
I think it was 44
okay,
let's find out too,
too,
too too too too.
George Foreman Big George [inaudible] and it's two two two two two second
retirement professional boxing record.
Let's see.
I'm Michael Moore.
Yup.
K O and round 10 and that was in 1994 that was 20 years ago.
Wow,
that's crazy.
Already on the day.
He is.
Okay.
How old is he?
Should be 64 65 so he was either 45 or 46 or it could have been 44 it might've
been 44 going on 45 let's see.
January 10th is his birthday.
So he was,
that was in January 10 1960 or 59 that was in May,
may 94,
may of [inaudible] 94 and his birthday was in,
uh,
January 10th the 49 49 Brian,
what's that?
Do the math?
59 no,
49 1949 it was cool.
Yeah.
He's 65 now.
[inaudible] 72 what?
No,
you're making things up.
Oh,
Shit.
January,
February,
March,
April.
I'm born before,
so yeah.
Uh,
that would be 46 46 yeah.
A 45 45 45 we split the difference.
Yeah.
10 years later he announced it come back and in November,
1994 at age 45,
he regained the heavyweight championship by knocking out 27 year old Michael
Moore.
I remember when he started his come back in [inaudible] 88 or 89 or 98 1889 I
think.
[inaudible] 88
yeah.
He's the oldest ever heavyweight champion.
And second oldest in any weight class after Bernard Hopkins who retired in 97 at
the age of 48 with a final record of 76 and five,
including 68 knockouts.
Credible.
Well,
didn't he?
He never ended up fighting Larry Holmes.
Diddy.
I do not believe he ever fought Larry Holmes and where they were calling each
other out at that age where they both when they were older.
Yeah.
Larry.
And then Larry Holmes called Trevor Berbick number.
He ran over a car and kicked Trevor.
Yes.
Rob kicked him.
Oh,
we're running out of time.
Do we have one minute to go raw so motherfucking Peter's.
Where can people see you perform?
I will be at the Irvine Improv.
January eight,
nine 10 11.
Good googly Mooglie I'll be in Florida the following weekend.
Yeah.
Florida following,
uh,
what's website?
Russell peters.com.
Russell Peters Dotcom.
You dirty flux at the real Russell P on Twitter and Instagram at the Real
Russell p.
Um,
this Friday,
January 2nd,
I'm at the Mirage in Vegas with Joey Diaz,
Ari Shaffir and Duncan Trussell.
Boom.
I'll be in town.
Welcome.
I'm gonna be hanging out with and we're going to hang out.
All right.
We're going to go check out some people beating the shit out of each other.
And,
uh,
that's just at the Strip club.
Oh.
But anyway,
uh,
Brian,
anything coming up real quick?
I Vegas next month,
next month.
Desk squad.
Dot TV for details on that,
and we'll see you Sooni dirty fucks.
We'll see you next year.
Thank you.
Good night.
Yeah.
Minute.